earlier today donald trump reported that
the fbi had seized his passports even
his expired passports are more than one
and now many people are saying that uh
he's a flight risk
perhaps because he has a jet that says
trump on it it's a very large one indeed
so i wonder why they would think he
would be a flight risk so um yeah that's
the only reason i can imagine that they
would do this now apparently the doj is
going to be releasing more information
on the affidavit we'll see where that
goes but uh this is all indicative of
they're probably going to criminally
charge trump earlier today i was saying
i didn't think it was going to happen i
still perhaps due to normalcy bias lean
towards there's no way they could they
could pull this off because it's
actually
it's getting trump supporters fired up
but maybe they don't care
maybe after this raid it looks way too
partisan maybe it backfired on them and
their only opportunity now is to lean
into it so we'll see donald trump has
warned that something terrible is is
going to happen to this country and it's
offering to help lower tensions i don't
know if that will be enough or what this
means but the fact that trump said it
actually suggests to me
it's worse than we probably realize when
trump is coming out saying things like
this because i think he knows
and uh we'll get into that we also have
predict it ron desantis is now favored
unpredicted to win and i see a lot of
people saying oh yeah but trump's
leading in the polls
predict it isn't a poll it's people
predicting which means if you ask
someone who they'd vote for they might
say trump if you ask someone who do they
think will win
they're saying ron desantis more than
trump but it's still fairly fair it's
still fairly close according to
predicted and it could be because people
expect trump to
be jammed up by the doj
so get into all that stuff before we get
started my friends head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and pick up your
keto elevate c8 mct oil powder from
biotrust again eat write and feel
well.com you'll get 51 off the keto diet
works wonders they say and uh i got to
tell you i'm not a nutritionist take the
advice from from a doctor not from me
but when i cut out the sugars and
started doing keto seriously within like
a month i lost like 20 pounds and then
since then it just been steadily down
and i'll say right now i'm officially in
about 168 169 and i was down from like
200 so no joke i was i just didn't care
and then i started taking this stuff
seriously and started doing more keto
and lost a ton of weight head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com you'll get a
60-day money-back guarantee it provides
keto elevate provides five grams of the
highly sought after mctc8 that is medium
chain triglycerides per scoop
free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help biotrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
you'll get free vip live health and
fitness coaching from biotrust's team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and their free new
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order again
eatrightandfeelwell.com but also don't
forget head over to timcast.com become a
member and you'll get access to our
uncensored after hours show those go up
monday through thursday at 11 pm and i
also want to announce
in less than uh next week
we are releasing our music video for the
song only ever wanted performed by tim
cast we got ian jam and some guitar the
song is almost entirely uh engineered
and produced by carter banks so it's
really really phenomenal stuff it's an
original song that i wrote carter
produced and turned into magic we got
pete perata on drums formerly of the
offspring super excited about this that
should be going up next week so you want
to check that one out and boy am i glad
that i lost weight before filming that
music video thanks keto elephant okay
that was an aside uh smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really do like it
joining us today to talk about the big
news is nick cersei
hello everybody glad to be here good i
usually don't come back places i'm glad
to be back here for the second time
doesn't happen i just uh we've had
enough of him yes so what do you do
i'm an actor and a director and a
producer and
a husband and a father and
that's about it all right on you got any
got any new movies that recently came
out
uh tara on the prairie came out not long
ago with the daily wire
was released in june and uh that's
that's out and ready to be viewed at
your leisure and i've got a movie coming
out later in the year called the old way
with nicholas cage
two westerns in one year so right on
right on and you you're in that with uh
gina chrono yeah among among others
awesome well look forward to uh talking
about all the news and we'll get into
all the creative projects and stuff we
also have hannah claire bremelo hi i'm
hannah claire brimley i'm a writer for
timcast.com i'm also co-hosting pop
culture crisis this week in mary's
absence so check that out at 3 p.m hi
everyone ian crossland from
iancrossland.net happy to be here nick i
also see you got a documentary behind
you i believe you produced that didn't
you working on that's right i produced
it and i conducted some of the
interviews capital punishment it's
available
capitalpunishment.locals.com
it's about what really happened on
january 6 then the aftermath that's that
that's going on for sure i think this is
just i mean forgiveness and i've been
talking a lot about pardons in general
maybe we can talk about this later on
the show but with trump coming out
talking about the escalation i think
this is very topical i'm glad you
brought that too
thanks man hi everyone all right i am
also here in the corner pushing buttons
love having hannah claire excuse me love
having nick back for sure i'm excited to
get into the news let's get going here's
the first big story from newsweek donald
trump labeled a flight risk after saying
fbi took his passports newsweek reports
trump wrote in a post on his truth
social platform that the fbi stole the
passports one of which he said was
expired during the search on august 8th
there's an assault on a political
opponent at a level never seen before in
our country third world he wrote while
trump did not offer any details on why
the fbi may have wanted the passports
some twitter users suggested that it was
because the ex-president was viewed as a
flight risk attorney seth abramson wrote
in a twitter thread on monday that if
the news was true the fbi is
acknowledging what i've long said is a
quote which is that as a factual matter
trump is a flight risk and i just got to
point out perhaps it was the giant 757
with trump's name on it that made them
concerned trump might be able to leave
the country but i also want to add just
very very quickly as well
for
you guys you know
people like trump don't live the way we
live all right donald trump does not
need a passport
donald trump is a billionaire donald
trump makes a phone call
actually donald trump doesn't make a
phone call when he when he charters his
flights his people probably call the
people of the country he's going to and
they don't need to verify donald trump's
identity and the amount of money that he
has and investments in many of these
countries they're going to roll out the
red carpet for them people don't realize
this stuff so i'm wondering why this
happened and of course there's some
speculation maybe that in the documents
they grabbed they didn't realize that a
box had trump's passports in it or
something
but i'm just not giving the benefit out
to the fbi i think they took his
passports i think their only option now
is to lean into if you're going after
the king you can't miss and so
earlier today i said i didn't think that
they would indict them with the
information coming out now that they
plan on releasing more information about
these affidavits
i'm starting to lean the other direction
i think they might have no choice but
again man i really don't know i don't
know what do you guys think
it bothers me that the doj is like we
oppose releasing the affidavit after
they claimed that they were going to
promote transparency i mean you can't
really have it both ways they're citing
national security concerns but again it
seems like everything is lined up they
just don't want to admit what they're
doing
and don't you have to be charged with
something before you become a flight
risk i mean they haven't really now
normally charged him with something i
mean look uh i'm not a lawyer i'm not a
criminal lawyer but i have watched law
and order oh yeah okay then the best
legal actions
no i'm pretty sure you can be instructed
not to leave uh during an investigation
but they didn't even do that but they
didn't do that that's what i mean it's
like there's i don't know why how you
can declare somebody a flight risk if
you haven't been charged with anything
where's it from yeah but i think he's
just i mean trump said he was declared a
flight risk right well no no people on
social media are saying this yeah and
this is just so it was nothing formal
it's just the fact that they are
pre-ordering they must have taken it
because they can't declare him one
officially they're just taking away his
ability to leave
they're not really yeah donald trump can
call saudi arabia and big listen i'm
coming in roll out the red cap and
they're good they're gonna do it like
sure they're gonna be bringing a very
nice plane it's one of the best planes
we'll get you on it i'll get your drinks
so so the question is
this is what's tough
the fbi didn't announce criminal charges
they're going to be releasing more
information it's they're saying it's
under a criminal investigation for
obstruction of justice and the espionage
act so i would say
yeah the fbi can't declare him
or or maybe they can't
formally seize his passports so they
just sort of took him they accidentally
took them in the raid yeah oops can't
leave we had no idea they were in that
box that we specifically put them in
what is this obstruction of justice for
what i guess is this january 6th i don't
know
the espionage act is related to the the
national archives
well the withholding of documents it
might be the classified document thing
right that they say he has all these
classified documents which he says he
declassified which he could declassify
simply by saying it yeah just by saying
everything i watched a video earlier
with uh comey talking with hillary
clinton just superimposed juxtaposed to
each other where he's saying we you know
in her emails we found 30 plus
110 110 classified pieces of information
in her gmail account i think it was all
on her gmail account saying it shouldn't
have been in a gmail account it wasn't a
private sector
you know a private hillary clinton
server had 110 classified documents
out of 30 000 public records that she
did not have the legal authority to
destroy keep that up keep that in mind
she had classified documents in her
personal server so let's just keep that
in mind i want to keep that in mind when
we're looking at talking about trump and
she's not a president she was secretary
of state which does not have uh
unilateral declassification powers
so here's what i try to explain to
people imagine you're the president
and you're going to negotiate with a
gorbachev about nuclear armaments
and you sit down and and you say look we
know you got missiles in turkey and you
gotta move those
and then he goes okay well then what
about your missiles that you have placed
in you know around us oh i can't talk
about that they're classified sorry i
have no idea
that's insane of course the president
can decide to tell an enemy about our
weapons he's the commander-in-chief he
has to be able to negotiate that it
would be it would be insane to us and be
like let me get back to you and see if i
can get the bureaucrats to determine if
i the president have the authority to
negotiate armaments that's what would be
happening with biden right now i don't
think that
yeah that's what you can't let biden
make ryden probably doesn't know
anything about the nuclear codes but
that's because they can't you know trust
him and they're not willing to admit
that where i think you're totally right
there's no way for trump to have been as
an effective leader as he could as he
was without anything to negotiate with
it doesn't make any sense but all
presidents every single one of them now
again
i'm seeing these memes go around where
it's you know it's like there's one meme
of like a little girl and she's got like
a shocked look on her face and it's like
if you chanted lock her up over
hillary's emails and now you are
defending trump let's just admit it was
never really about the emails and then i
just i'm like i'm gonna i'm gonna
respond on facebook because i waste time
trolling sometimes or i should say
trolling and uh i just responded with
very matter of fact sordid politifact uh
several sources said hillary clinton had
110
confidential amazon a private server and
they politely investigated and then said
there was no intent have a nice day even
though she's she was secretary of state
with no declassification power donald
trump after kevin kleinsmith was
sentenced to probation for fabricating
evidence to justify spying on the
president you can't expect me to believe
that trump has done something wrong no
the the the benefit of the doubt is gone
and you need to prove you had a
legitimate reason to do this
but still donald trump as the president
has broad declassification powers so i
just don't see anything here not to
mention the the warrant for the search
of trump's home said from the first day
of his presidency the last day of his
presidency how is that constitutional
the fourth amendment if it prohibits
you know unreasonable search and seizure
you need to be able to be like we
believe you have this document that says
this thing and we're going to prove it
instead they're just like i don't think
it all
every single thing you got yes and then
an epstein judge signed off on it how
about that i'm sorry a judge who had
been a lawyer defending epstein's
lieutenant i want to make sure i'm being
clear on that one because it's actually
worse than so much worse yeah so bad i
don't know i've seen had lieutenants who
are they
yeah
my friend larry correa who's an author
he said if i'd put that in a book that
the judge who signed this affidavit
worked for epstein people would say oh
come on editors are rejected be like
it's a little too much
well there are so many outlets that are
like we're just gonna skip reporting
that we don't want to mention it because
it starts to sound as sketchy as it
really is yeah that's a really crazy
story right it's all you know there's a
a bunch of viral me
viva fry i think posted this
it's a it's a ma it's a montage or a is
it a music
mural it's whatever mural it's not
really a mural i guess it's a it's a
montage of pictures all of these
verified individuals saying
that they've gotten coveted and they're
so grateful to be vaccinated protected
now i'm not going to comment on the
covet nonsense the cdc put out
guidelines saying that their policies
now for the unvaccinated vaccine are the
same or whatever i'm not here to comment
on that i'm here to comment on the
identical posting of all of these people
around the world makes me feel like
there's like one guy behind all the
accounts just copying and pasting
everything and then i saw that and i was
like
when you when you you guys ever see that
video that that's been put together
where all of the news anchors are saying
the exact same yeah yeah it just feels
like that it's like it's it it really
just feels like there's a machine like
it's all fake these people aren't real
people they're not saying real things
they're not having real thoughts
and there are world leaders who are of
that and there are news anchors who are
of that and that's freaky
there it is a machine and people are
being fed a narrative but the the crazy
part is it's not fake it's real they're
real people they're just allowing
themselves to be changed by their
superiors it reminds me of the phrase
party line like when i'm researching
stories to write for the site you know
you'll see that ap news put out a story
ap news does that a lot and then it gets
picked up in 87 different places and
there's no other original reporting into
this so you just have the party line
repeated over and over again the same
statistics the same quotes the same
perspective but because it's multiple
outlets they're acting like oh yes we're
all reporting this very important story
that actually only one of us wrote it's
why the theory that there's like one guy
putting out the same post for every
country like it doesn't seem that crazy
to me because they just copy what their
the other people are doing dead internet
theory you guys you guys know about that
you know about that nick dead internet
theory the idea is that sometime around
2016 the internet basically became fake
like almost all of the posts are made by
ai and bots to manipulate public opinion
and the average person doesn't really
engage anymore
and uh
i don't know if i would believe that but
i would believe that mass censorship was
enacted on such a scale that the average
person has no voice and only a small
percentage of approved people are
actually posting and that's that's
pretty much reality yeah well i'm so
shadow band i mean you know i
my posts don't get very much penetration
ever on twitter right
i think
we see it a lot that uh when it comes
censorship high profile people get
censored periodically but it's always
the smaller accounts who get hit
instantly without notice and without
reason it doesn't make sense and i hear
this from people when i go out and talk
you know i'll meet some regular guys
like i had 100 followers and they banned
me because i posted a news story and who
are you going to tell what are you going
to do about it right so that kind of
makes me feel like
you know if we go back to when elon musk
was trying to buy twitter and now he
apparently doesn't want to buy it when
that weird shift happened and overnight
people associated with like libertarian
conservative or independent also a
message massive gain and subscribers on
the left saw message drop off
really does make you think the dead
internet theory might be real and we're
just arguing with bots 24 7.
the internet was what darpa tech arpa
arpa it was uh military technology
basically it was i think it's it was
created as a weapon basically or is like
it's gonna get created so let's create
it first and it was like the internet
yeah and now it's being used like i mean
i was watching jimmy you know bright
insight he does uh research on i know
his last name is but jimmy is his first
name his youtube channel is bright
inside talking about search results
coming back and like he would search
like january 6 and then you'd say 800 or
8 billion search results here you go and
every page you'd go to
would be showing them the same results
it would be wikipedia at the top a
certain january 6 uh page they want you
to see then you go to like next page
wikipedia at the top the same article
again on the next page next page same
thing
this is google and then he tried a
different search engine i think he used
like duckduckgo and he was getting the
same problem so i think it's becoming
very clear that the the military is
using it if it's not the military i
don't know who but someone is using the
internet right now as a tool well yeah
greater than the masses that are also
using it as a tool it could be it could
be emergent in that special interests
and corporations
you know for one reason or another are
pushing in this direction you can say
it's political you can say it's criminal
you can say it's it's it's capitalistic
or whatever but there's an incentive for
google in these companies to do what
they do i honestly think you know i
don't have have you watched the orville
seth macfarlane's space show no i'm not
on it so i don't watch shows that i'm
not on oh okay i'll make sure i feel
like that's the opposite of what a lot
of actors say like i'd never watch my
own movies
the orville started as like
comedy star trek and they did a new
season on hulu which is dead serious
actually i think it's really good they
had one episode where there's a planet
of only men that are trying to force
gender transition babies and they're
like basically people are smuggling
little girls off it's it's it's crazy
but anyway in one of the later episodes
they talk about how when there's no
currency anymore because in their sci-fi
future they invented matter replicators
like star trek and so
they're like there's no more need for
for money or currency and so this person
from a lesser developed world says then
why would anyone do anything
and one of the characters explains you
know to to do good for society and it
got me thinking about where we are now
in the united states and why people
aren't working
somehow people aren't working they have
money i don't know you had that cnn news
anchor who said
that uh i can't remember her name but
she was quitting as part of the great
resignation and so i'm seeing something
happen where all of these people are
quitting their jobs
announcing it on tv and i'm like you
must have money where you don't need to
work
how are people not working well we heard
with pilots for instance as a shortage
because they all retire
it seems like what we're seeing right
now is what happens to a society when
currency is not particularly valuable
and survival is easy
virtue becomes currency so instead of
trying to have cash and use cash to
flaunt your your wealth wealth is
meaningless everybody's got air
conditioning everybody's got clean
drinking water everybody's got a hot
shower so what do you have to flaunt
well some people will get gold chains
and some people will stand up on a
pedestal and scream about how virtuous
they are one by one more and more people
start seeing virtue as wealth and virtue
as currency and you get hyper
polarization cult-like behaviors from
the from the from the mass media which
ultimately leads to
just societal breakdown i suppose so in
that regard
when i look at these sci-fi depictions
of a future with no currency and i'm
like they didn't see this one coming
what they predicted was everybody would
be like i'm gonna make society better
but what they didn't predict was how
does making society better manifest it
manifests with creepy weirdos talking
about giving children sex changes and
things like that they they they don't
know what better is nobody does right
and it becomes subjective it's like your
idea better is not the the other guy's
idea better so and i think it's also
some atlas shrugged going on you know i
think there's there's some aspect to it
it's like if you're not going to get
ahead if what you're working for
suddenly is meaningless and the money
doesn't mean what it used to mean then
why are you going to put forth all that
effort why are you going to work that
hard when you don't have to i'll give
you a really good example timcast.com
i
i always talk about how we started this
not because of money it's like i started
making videos because i care about
something
everything has become mission driven
when i was working for that abc news
joint venture fusion they said the
future is mission driven storytelling
now in their minds it was going to make
them money
and then uh you know like people will
click on it it'll work and that's a
capitalistic way to view it ultimately
it goes insane becomes woke because woke
is the safest path for a lot of these
people for for us here
you know
the people who are working here at
timcast are doing it because we believe
in what we're doing and we want to do
something good it's very much like
virtue based currency now obviously you
need hard currency so people can eat
food and pay rent and all that stuff but
i think you know for for better or for
worse
you're going to have a society built
upon who is actually doing good who
thinks they're doing good and who is
doing bad
but like but thinking they're doing good
how that will end up playing out
there's no guarantee anyone wins but i
can say
cheaters win man you know as much as
people want to rag on cheating
if you cheat you don't get caught if
there's if there's a hundred people
racing and someone cheats they're gonna
win i mean you look at you look at these
uh uh you know blood doping you look at
uh the tour de france was lance
armstrong accused of i don't want to
accuse him because i don't know the full
details but cheaters win and they win
for a long time and they get all the
glory and stuff so just look at
professional wrestling they've been
winning for years the cheaters
right deals that's right i mean allowing
someone to take a chair from the stands
and use it
chairs should be banned from those
arenas and the refs the ref's not
looking and that's right and then we all
see it happen that's right i think once
you get a certain amount of cheaters in
society that they start
cheating each other and you start to see
a more value of honesty there's this
weird simulation i wish i could remember
what it was called anyway i don't want
to go too deeply into it but it shows
you like it would give you like what if
you have 99 honest people and one
percent cheaters well the cheaters
actually win in those situations
they went in all situations not unless
there's cheaters if it's 99 cheaters
they tend to cannibalize themselves and
then you find virtue coming out hard for
them to win against one another that's a
good point actually but it's also who
gets to define cheating
you know if if you have the government
that says cheating is actually fair
you know which is what you have in
california
you know you can't get those people out
of audience out of out of office because
you can't vote them out
it's not possible well it's like
changing the definition of inflation
right but but but we'll clarify that i
think you can vote them out the problem
is
you've got a zombie cult you've got like
imagine this if everybody woke up at the
same time and in california and voted
then yes those politicians would be gone
the problem is
these people believe the lies from the
media and there's no convincing them
like you can show them every article
article in the world that that russia
gate was a lie ukraine gate was a lie
these people still believe justice
millet these people believe the nuclear
document story that just came out there
was no evidence
washington post cited anonymous sources
familiar with what the agents were
looking for and that was fact
responsible factual reporting how do you
convince someone
like if they keep believing all this
stuff after lie after life after lie to
do something else you you don't do it i
mean i don't know how you do it well
there's a lot of those people but
there's also a lot of other people in
california there's a lot of people like
me
that that don't believe that stuff and
i'm telling you right now i think newsom
was recalled but the way they structured
it the the mail-in ballots and
everything they did look what they just
did with the gas company
they disallowed over 200 000 votes out
of the 750 200 000 signatures out of the
715 000.
they just disallowed those so that the
recall didn't work so so in that we'll
definitely get into that story for sure
yeah the the recall they've said that uh
like 88 000 were not registered voters
they you know they said and then we have
to verify those things but the issue i
take with the like it's too defeatist
for me man it's it's it's frustratingly
defeatist you you've got right now
a historical defeat that's that's
supposed to be coming in the midterms
and every time someone comes out and
says no you can't win like then people
give up and then they don't vote yeah
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy when in
reality donald trump won and they were
and it caused such chaos and tumult
twice
for the establishment
that it's it's it's it's
it's brutal chaos so no i disagree uh
the thing is though like look he won in
2016 pretty handedly and and we saw not
really
it wasn't you're right it wasn't it
wasn't uh 88 000 votes in between
shoestring and that but that's just
because they didn't steal enough i mean
that's what they that's why they were so
mad in 2016 is they thought they had
stolen enough i really don't think so
i think
they wouldn't have run hillary clinton
who's like
she thought it was her turn they think
they're invincible and they lost
and and and i think it's quite honestly
i think it's kind of insane to think
that donald trump actually wins they
have to use the full fort of the force
of the doj to go after him to jam him up
but then this idea is that trump
secretly won the whole time i really
they're they're going after trump with
the doj because they have no idea how to
stop him from winning if it was true
that they could cheat in the elections
they would not be in going after trump
they would not be raiding his house they
would not be taking his passports they'd
sit back and laugh because they're the
cabal but the reality is trump got 74
million votes he got 12 million more
votes than last time now i certainly
think we can take a look at 2020 because
you know i've seen all the stuff that
came out in 2000 mules and i think there
are questions for sure but the reality
is covid lockdown
sports are gone movies are gone and then
i get to watch all of my my skateboard
friends who don't know what supreme
court justice even means post videos of
themselves dropping mail-in ballots for
joe biden and then what happens is
donald trump comes out a month later
telling everybody that's not actually
why he lost and then they lose the
senate because of it trump won in 2016.
trump and
the republicans and the establishment
and many states
voted to change rules that heavily
favored democrats whether they realized
it or not probably a lot of them
realized it was going to happen now they
have to use the fbi and the doj to go
after trump because he will win in 2024
unless they weaponize the doj against
them because they don't have control of
the election system see i disagree
because they're going out they're not
just going after trump they're going
after everybody who supports trump which
proves their desperation and inability
to control an election
no which proves that they that's part of
the cheating they're trying to
neutralize all the people that do
support if they if they could cheat why
would they need to go after trump's
support and why would they need to try
and indict him because they cheated in
2016 and it wasn't enough and they know
now that it's even worse that makes no
sense it makes perfect sense to me they
lost in 2016
then they sent russia gate after trump
they sent ukraine gate after trump they
made up lie after lie in the media over
and over and over again
and that worked
but tim you just said trump got 12
million more votes that's right in 2020
then by 2016.
you don't think that that happened
because they cheated there's no way that
joe biden got 81 million votes you're
wrong
there's no way he got 20 million but
more votes than obama that's right
did obama have a pandemic
before obama did they shut down movies
allowed them to do the mail-in ballots
and mail-in ballots gives huge
advantages to democrat to urban centers
regardless of anything else so if your
argument is that it was cheating to
change the election system like in
pennsylvania by implementing universal
mail and voting i understand your point
the issue i take is when people started
claiming like
uh widespread fraud and things like that
and the issue with it is they didn't
need widespread fraud they needed fraud
in six counties
so if
so to clarify then that is what i refer
to with the idea of widespread fraud the
issue is it's extremely easy for
democrats in six counties to spend tons
of money to go door-to-door and say fill
that out put in the box right there did
you do it i'll wait republicans can't do
that when that happens it is extremely
easy when you've taken away people's
jobs when you've taken away their
entertainment when you've blamed trump
the entire time when donald trump
started doing pressers nightly cnn and
all these other outlets immediately they
cancelled uh showing his live events
because it was improving his ratings the
whole goal was to manipulate people into
voting in their direction it is it is i
i'm honestly uh is flab i'm
flabbergasted at the idea that trump did
win in 2016 but people still think they
cheated which i don't understand he won
he literally won they've been cheating
for decades damn but it wouldn't just
start in 2016.
i'm talking fraud voter fraud they've
been stuffing ballots they've been
fighting look at what happened with the
minnesota senate race with al franken
trump is evidence of the contrary what
happened with al franken in minnesota
well they they kept finding more votes
that's how al franken got in the first
time it's like he lost and then they
said oh we found these 500 votes that
were in the back of a church or they
found something in the back of a car
they found enough votes and they've been
doing this for for years
they they've been doing it since kennedy
nixon i think it's not out of the
ballpark to suggest that it's it's
definitely possible that people have
been cheating voting systems since the
dawn of man but
without hard evidence it's impossible to
make valid claims
i just and it's people that cheat are
very good at hiding the evidence which
is you know so that's why
criminals don't get caught i'll tell you
i'll tell you what bugs me is there's
there's a lot of stuff that came out in
2020 that uh
was was easily proven false and it and
it's it's frustrating the the there was
that um
that that video of ballots being pulled
out from under tables
and it was just like if you watch the
actual security footage you watch them
take bouts and put them in boxes and put
them under the table and then you watch
for several hours they pull them out and
then they start counting all the same
time and i'm like those ballots came in
the same like normally and people were
like posting these memes claiming that
the ballots came out of nowhere from
under the table and i'm like watch the
full video please but what's really
frustrating is for one i fully support
an inquiry investigation into all of the
elections every single one of them
after after
a year and a half
there's nothing to show for it i mean
i've had multiple people on talk about
this over and over again and it's
surprising to me that despite causing
the defeat of republicans in the senate
republicans kill still keep saying over
and over again that they can't win it's
like bro november is in three months you
need to be telling people the opposite
you need to be telling them you can win
you're going to win make sure you get
every single one of your friends out to
go vote instead you've got people coming
out being like what's the point you're
going to lose anyway that that to me is
insane i'm not saying you can't win i'm
saying they they're going to cheat
and you have to overcome the cheating
and you have to find it whenever you you
can how come they have how come they've
only found
uh they found circumstance or uh they've
found questionable matters what happened
to the arizona audit what's going on
like we actually have those guys go down
into that full thing we had constant
talk about it's coming next week it's
coming next week look i have no problem
if an audit actually happens and they
find evidence of something by all means
please bring it out but to me it is just
it is just insane that this line of
thinking destroys the ability of
republicans to win and after a year and
a half of constant talk there's been
literally nothing
what you just said if an audit actually
happens
it hasn't actually happened so the
arizona thing with all the color
coordination and the big tables and the
millions of dollars wasn't an audit
i don't know what it was i think look i
think trump supporters
have wishful thinking that they can't
believe that outside their bubble people
hated donald trump like they they
haven't gone to a city and seen trump
derangement syndrome
i've seen trump derangements in such a
degree i can genuinely believe that as i
said to steve bannon when i see a guy
that has never uttered the word politics
in his life film himself holding his
mail in ballot and walk to a mailbox
while saying it's time to do what's
right and vote and i'm like this guy
doesn't know who ruth bader ginsburg is
he doesn't even know what the phrase
supreme court justice means and somehow
he went out and voted i'll tell you why
they dumped tons of sand into the skate
park so he couldn't skate anymore and
when he showed up they said it's because
donald trump start cause failed to
address the pandemic when you when when
every facet of your life is shut down
and the media tells you it's trump's
fault
there's nothing left to do people are
bored they have nothing i was in
california when they dumped the sand
into the pits out there
they didn't i mean that would everybody
knew that was news from doing that
but people when when they
go and they look to the tv and obviously
i'm speaking in general and say
everybody obviously the people who hate
news um they're republicans republicans
weren't going to blame trump for this
but my normie friends who have no idea
what's going on they don't know who
newsome is they've never heard the word
newsome before they turn on the tv and
they're like because of donald trump the
pandemic is worse and they're going dude
i just want his gate man and then along
come the democrats knocking on the door
being like well then you better go vote
for biden because if trump stays and
you're never skating again and they film
themselves doing this stuff
hell that's more defeatist than me
saying
that the the cheating if everybo
everybody's that stupid then there
really is no hope well there is it is
doing shows like this it is telling
people to go and tell their friends it
is telling they're telling people to go
and share as many videos as possible
it's telling people to engage in polite
discourse and be careful about how you
address people who are in the cult and
it's about telling people definitively
trump won the first time in 2016 because
they were arrogant and they were
laughing about how trump could never win
and then he did and then they went nuts
in the other direction saying trump will
win trump will win and then they were
able they managed to get these votes i
don't think uh joe biden mustered the
votes i think donald trump got votes
against him i think donald trump was
anti-elected i think what happens is you
take away movies sports you take away
events every every major venue is shut
down all the big for me all the
skateboard companies were like
all everything's closed businesses were
destroyed and what do they do they turn
on msnbc abc nbc cnn who all say one
thing it's trump's fault
you have to imagine that will work
and if that messaging is happening and
we're moving we're moving we immediately
went from that into the special election
in georgia
they even showed on like cnn a guy
outside
a voting voting uh station polling
station saying i'm not going to vote
because they cheated anyway and then i'm
like there it is
thanks to this narrative you've just
you've just suppressed your own vote and
sure enough democrats got 50 50 in the
senate i i think there's nefarious bs
that happens at the highest level with
politics i think these people play dirty
games all day and night i think there's
trading tit for tat for rule changes the
pennsylvania republicans that did it did
a deal with the democrats to implement
universal mail in voting because they
thought eliminating the down ballot vote
would benefit republicans not realizing
universal mail and voting would
basically destroy their chances of
winning either because they hated trump
they wanted to cut a deal or they were
just really dumb but that literally
happened democrats won in pennsylvania
because of universal mail in voting
because republicans in october of 20 of
2019 agreed to it through a formal
process it was challenged the supreme
court of pennsylvania recently upheld
the constitutionality which i think is
wrong you can argue their ruling was
incorrect you can argue that's cheating
i hear you but i just think it's
important to clarify because we're three
months out for from the november midterm
election and i am really really trying
to make sure that everybody has the full
charge storm into battle mentality of
getting all of their friends going out
and proving that they can win
do you think there's a significant part
of the republican party that is part of
the swamp that hates trump i think
that's
that's most of them most of them that's
right which is so that's why some of the
republicans have agreed to some of the
things that you you're talking about but
i think it's important to clarify what
cheating is right because there are
people who think they're servers in
venezuela there are people who think
that the bouts weren't real ballots in
the first place like they came from
china and things like that and that was
the big narrative after the election the
narrative so you know clarifying what it
means when time magazine publishes an
article called the shadow campaign to to
to save the election and they literally
call it a conspiracy i'm like okay if
you want to say it's rigged because of
the time magazine i call i i get it for
sure but i think it's important to say
that there are establishment policies
and procedures that negatively impact
the the populist left and right chances
for winning i think that powerful elites
in both parties desperately want to stop
trump and they're cutting deals to
change policy and procedure
that negatively impact the chance for
trump supporters to get in and then you
take a look at the
what's been going on and i think
right now in the past several months
with the primaries with the trump
america first uh candidates winning
across the board like i think this shows
outright you can win
that you should not be holding on to
these ideas uh of they're gonna cheat or
whatever it's like whatever is going to
happen you just need to get all of your
friends and go vote whatever you think
can happen but i just want to stress i
think the fact that we just saw carrie
lake win and it was it was a nail biter
because
you know at night she was down and i was
like
come on and then she wins
sweeping the entire state it's no
surprise maricopa was almost going the
other direction because it's very it's
very urban liberal it's very you know
democrat leaning but she ends up
swimming across the board joe kent wins
all of these trump maga candidates are
winning if the party really had the
power to stop them these guys would not
be winning if trump could win in the
first place they wouldn't if then it
proves he can win and i'll stress it
again
they are trying to it appears indict
donald trump because they can't stop him
from winning so that that i'll leave it
at that because i don't want to just
keep ranting every every time someone
comes up with this it's like we have to
go into a full like tirade uh explaining
you know my views on this but it's
primarily
because
november the election is less than three
months away and everybody needs to have
in their hearts you can win
i i do not i do not believe it is it is
i don't believe that narrative well i
hope you're right
i don't agree with you but i hope you're
right this is one something that comes
up amazing no that's great the problem
like it's not going to stop me from
voting i'm still going to vote is when
that there's a corporation called
dominion or whatever you want to call
these different corporations that tally
the votes on their mechanical on their
digital machines behind the scenes the
problem that people make is when they
come out and they say they cheated
because you don't know they're doing it
in secret so you don't know if they're
cheating or if they're working honestly
the problem for me is the not knowing i
think that that needs to be transparent
so we can verify whether it was accurate
or inaccurate i agree i i i think this
is the most important point dominion
should should not be our voting machines
should be all open source publicly
available
and why aren't they well that's a that's
a rabbit hole that we could definitely
ponder on you know favorite topic for
you it's crazy but good question i mean
but it's it's the it's the most
important thing set of anything
pertaining to any of this at the end of
the day regardless of what you think
about the election what needs to happen
is
we need to have sweeping reform on our
election systems that if we're going to
go electronic the source code has to be
publicly viewable and very easy very
easily accessible
and even then let's let's be real who's
going to understand the source code
but this means
everyone will be allowed so there's
equal playing field every political
party can hire their tech specialist to
review it that's what needs to happen or
paper ballots but with the entire
democrat party and half the republican
party opposed to that how do you think
that's ever going to happen i mean i
think that the republican party knows
their base likes trump i mean it's
impossible think about wyoming's coming
up this week liz cheney is trailing
harry higman like there's no tomorrow i
mean like there is no recovering from
that race i mean it would really take a
very serious landslide even with uh
there are
like rumors that there'll be democrats
who will vote in their primary it's not
enough it's a republican-held state
i think that even though there are parts
of the party that don't support trump
they have seen the tides turn i mean
it's almost impossible to deny that
trump's popularity is solid and they
risk their own seats by trying to ally
themselves with the narrative that's
losing with their voters wyoming is the
number one trump supporting state
so
i don't even know if they have enough
democrats to actually swing this
election they do not yeah
but there there was a poll showing
democrats were planning on sure voting
for liz cheney i think
yeah i think what we need to realize
about our election system is that the
whole thing
elections are not as simple as someone
walks up signs about hands it in and
then we cross our fingers we got the
votes this is not high school there are
back room deals there's gerrymandering
there's parliamentarianism there's a
whole bunch of stuff that goes into this
the the redistricting of states it's
like it's it's
hey elections have consequences based on
the census which they admit they get
wrong i mean it's just crazy so so the
the reality of it is
when uh in pennsylvania is the best
example they changed the voting law so
to implement universal mail-in voting
seemingly in violation of their own
constitution and we had sean parnell on
talking about this that
they actually initially they changed the
language of the bill they were gonna
introduce because they realized it
violated the constitution a lower court
actually agreed with them and said we
think this will be found you know
sustained on the merits and then
ultimately got thrown out for standing
just before 2020
then it was found earlier this year to
be unconstitutional the voting system
universal mail and voting in
pennsylvania was deemed by a lower court
unconstitutional the the supreme court
of pennsylvania i believe the supreme
court just upheld it as constitutional
saying nothing in the in the
pennsylvania constitution forbids
universal mail and voting that's an
argument to make in court the
constitution says absentee ballots must
be for these reasons
and their argument is mail and voting
and absentee are not the same thing
okay okay well that's that's that's
ridiculous but this went through a legal
process and now we've got a very serious
problem in this country as it pertains
to pennsylvania but
that finally made it through it's going
to be interesting i think one thing that
needs to happen is
republicans need to realize it's an
uphill battle with mainland voting
and uh
if if that's the case you all better
start driving to all of your friends
houses as soon as as soon as early
voting starts because the democrats this
is what i try to explain to people in
one unit in manhattan you might have 1
000 voters
one building
and and two people
can knock on all of those doors in a day
and they knock on the door there's an
answer and they say you got your mailing
ballot it's right there why don't you
fill it out all you got to do is put it
right here in the mailbox by your door
the mailman will come take it or you
just throw it under your floor or drop
it downstairs in your mailbox mailman
i'll come and take you don't got to do
anything
that works if a republican wants to do
that they got to drive in a rural area
what you know quarter of a mile every
every house they go to to get one or two
voters so this is why i think universal
mainland voting was entirely
negotiated by democrats to benefit
themselves
you can argue the republicans in
pennsylvania sold out trump because they
hated them but they got they got a deal
too they they had that down ballot thing
where people in pennsylvania could just
vote but let's advance from this topic
so i don't just beat a dead horse
because we do have this story from the
south china morning post
civil war and dirty bombs fbi and u.s
department of homeland security on alert
for threats after raid on trump home u.s
law enforcement agencies prepare for
potentially violent fallout from fbi
raid on donald trump's mar-a-lago home
fbi and dhs identify multiple
articulated threats and calls for the
targeted killing of judicial law
enforcement and government officials
yo there's uh
there's another story from axios that
goes along with it that um
i don't even know if i can start getting
into because the language used by this
guy is so egregious
pennsylvania man are arrested for
threatening slaughter fbi this is what
it's
i don't know you guys ready to drink
civil war oh my so i said it the first
time in the title of the south china
morning post article but
i'll tell you this while the fbi is
claiming there are these very real
threats and that there's there's
concerned about him
jane's revenge has admitted to engaging
in terrorism they've taken credit for
this and where's the fbi i'll tell you
where it is no it's just marjorie taylor
green trying to get them declared a uh
domestic terrorist organization i mean
the fbi is not just it's literally her i
mean i'm sure she has support in
congress but like no one is taking
action against james revenge remember
when like when you're reading the
headline they're like they're
threatening uh government officials do
you remember when that guy showed up at
brett kavanaugh's house i mean they're
acting like
you know violence is one-sided which it
really is not in this country and
obviously i think most threats come from
extremists that don't represent the
majority of people on either side of the
spectrum but
this is
this is very bizarre but we forget that
it's double-sided i i think it's
actually simple if you're the fbi and
you're raiding donald trump
the right is very mad at you if you're
the fbi and you're investigating trump
for russiagate the right is very mad at
you and so imagine you're sitting in
your chair
and you're you know reading the news and
all of a sudden antifa is just screaming
they hate you you're evil you're corrupt
and then people on the right are not
really saying a whole lot you'd be like
man these guys are crazy over here they
won't stop talking about how they want
to do evil stuff
this is what the fbi is basically doing
for one they're i mean this is an
example of their overt political bias
they engage in weaponized politicking
going after trump for russiagate clearly
fake the fbi uh uh kevin kleinsmith i
believe his name was
altered an email fabricating evidence to
justify spying on the trump campaign
then trump supporters get mad at the fbi
say you're all corrupt then a bunch of
other fbi agents who are not involved
and don't know that this corruption is
occurring just think the trump
supporters are crazy because hey i
didn't do anything wrong
then the fbi starts pointing at the
people who are pointing at them and
they're completely ignoring antifa in
the far left and
cherry on top they're getting all their
news from the corporate press who's been
actively defending you know antifa and
the left to a great degree not all the
time but to a great degree
so
it's not so much i would say that you
need to be concerned about a conspiracy
but an emergent phenomenon where these
are the things that are causing the fbi
to be inflamed like to target trump
supporters on the right
well they've drummed out over the years
they've gotten rid of the people in the
fbi that were
there they that were not
willing to do this kind of thing to
demonize people that support trump this
is part of just demonizing anybody that
disagrees with the powers that be
that's what they've been doing since
january 6th it's what they they that's
why they've been terrorizing american
citizens who just went to washington on
january 6 and weighed flags and that's
why when you have an actual person who
is camped outside of brett kavanaugh's
house and is going to kill him that
mentioned for a couple of days but then
they make these sweeping pronouncements
right about all these threats it's the
same thing as when they declared all the
parents that went to school board
meetings as potential domestic
terrorists everything everybody that
disagrees with the uh weaponized fbi
with with you know the government's
the fbi has become our stasi now they
are just investigating people who they
consider to be enemies of the
administration enemies of the government
people who disagree
why aren't they going
why do you think they're just not going
after uh jane's revenge or the left i
mean maybe they are they just don't care
they absolutely don't care they they
agree with jane's revenge they're not
going to investigate them just like they
you know the blm and antifa riots in
2020 and 2021 they didn't do they didn't
treat those people the way they're
treating the january six people so we've
talked about something a bit in the past
couple of weeks that um
if joe biden were to pardon all of the
january 6 people that his popularity
would spike democrats would start
cheering and clapping about how gracious
they are and trump supporters wouldn't
have much to say other than well that
was the right thing to do thank you for
doing it
do you think that sorry they can't do
that the biden would never ever do that
and i don't think his democrat base
would cheer that they would be furious i
disagree
they they don't care for
lot moral logic they care for winning
and if joe biden does something they'll
say we are good people while donald
trump was chanting lock em up we are
doing the right thing and and reaching
an olive branch because we are honorable
that's of course what they would do i
don't think so i don't think you
understand how deeply they hate people
like me i think i i do but i think
they they care more about
they wouldn't want to claim to claim
defeat if if joe biden came out and said
look
tensions have gotten way beyond our
control in this country we need a sign
of good faith
you know and then he says something like
what these men these people on january 6
did was wrong however
the continued prosecution is only
ripping this country apart and we need
to find a path towards you know clemency
and you know commutation for these
individuals so that we can learn to heal
as a nation i think the left would
absolutely have no choice the democrats
but to agree with biden otherwise they'd
be claiming defeat and they're not going
to do that they're not going to admit
they're wrong they're going to say see
we were the good guys the whole time
it's trump who's bad and we're honorable
and then trump supporters could only say
well that was the right thing to do
thank you joe biden some might be alike
it's political it's a political move but
it would be such a tremendous and
gracious move you'd have no choice but
to be like oh okay all right you know
that's the most outlandish alternate
universe i've ever heard of you you
think the democrats would be angry
absolutely they're bloodthirsty they
want everybody in jail they want
everybody that went to washington on
january 6th in jail forever i i i agree
but my point is that when faced with
having to admit that their guy betrayed
what they truly wanted they're more
about virtue signaling they wouldn't
throw a bite under the bus biden
is is implementing policy that's
damaging to our energy sector and they
claim the opposite they it's like biden
literally
is enacting policy that causes gas
prices to go up and they come out and
they say biden can't control gas prices
then when it comes down they're like
biden did that
there's no moral consistency whatever
biden does is good and they were right
and just so that's why uh you know look
and look i'm not i'm not i'm not trying
to argue that it's absolutely true i'm
just trying to get your thoughts on it
because you know one of the things that
we're bringing up is how do we
de-escalate tensions is that one of the
ways we do it right biden coming out
just being like
the only way to simmer things down is to
is to pardon these guys well he's never
going to do that but yeah i agree with
you that if he did that might work but i
i don't see that i don't see anything
like that happening sometimes i think if
he were to do that it's the only way the
democrats would admit that he is like in
early stages of dementia or maybe not
early stages
because then they would be like see he's
really not in a position to be doing
this like
i think you're right it would be
extremely difficult for a huge section
of the democratic party to justify this
to themselves i think tim's right there
would be some who would be like well
because of this
illogical
twisting of argument then this is why it
makes sense to do that but i do think
there would be enough who would say
you know no he should only be pardoning
you know african-american men who have
done this like to pardon a majority
white crowd that went to this you know
like it would be
it would be really against narrative and
upstream and that's where i think they
would be like well i mean like if he had
done it his first day in office
maybe because they had enough they know
he's going to be in office for a little
while but yeah he's halfway through
almost halfway through at this point we
can all kind of tell things are not
right we do not expect to run again if
he were to uh pardon all of january 6
prisoners which of course i wish he
would uh
he would probably just get well it's
time for biden to retire we didn't
really want him here anyways and how do
you get from the worst attack on our
nation's democracy since the civil war
to i'm just going to pardon it it's
covet you i mean we got to acknowledge
that covet caused massive strain and
stress on people's psychology it's not
just shutting down what happened as a
result of covet in the response to covet
but the covet virus when i had it i was
angry man and i was stressed out and tim
and me got into it one day we were
yelling like it it it causes people to
feel like crap and to get madness so
many people went nuts over the last two
and a half years like pardon all those
people that were smashing up buildings
in the summer of 2020 pardon them pardon
hillary clinton pardoned james clapper
for lying under oath pardon the prison
people that are sitting
solitary we need to we need to scrub
clean the last 200 years of insanity
that we've declared on ourselves the
slaveholders pardon them all man pardon
all the runaway slaves pardon them all
and like wendy's part and literally
everybody else like fresh start everyone
you're right that's right you snap your
fingers
would you keep pardoning people after
that though like i i understand the
instinct to want to be like let's just
start over but i think that like the
memories of everything that's happened
runs too deep you wouldn't actually give
people a sense of justice or
satisfaction it would just be like we're
making the score zero except we all
secretly know it's not zero i don't
think abe lincoln thought he was doing
like what was politically correct when
he freed the slaves he just knew it had
to happen he said
anything to keep the union together he
wouldn't have pardoned the slaves if he
could have kept the union together he
did not it wasn't about morality for him
it was about preserving the sovereignty
of the nation and the economy and it was
also about destabilizing the south
because the emancipation proclamation
was
basically saying to all of the slaves
which were in southern states because
the north states were free
rise up against
the the the government there it was it
was weaponization of if anything i mean
i mean look abraham lincoln got in
the civil war had technically already
begun bleeding kansas was going on
several states had already seceded and
so he waited several years to actually
the free the slaves things wasn't a
civil war it was like the civil war was
going to happen anyway and then he
sought as an opportunity to do what he
thought was right i think you're wrong
and he took a bullet for it i mean what
it wasn't it wasn't like free the slaves
and then the civil war started it was
like years later that they decided to
freeze right right it wasn't it so
abraham lincoln your argument that he
maybe wanted more troops and they wanted
southern slaves to fight on the side of
the world it was by destabilization yeah
it's partly about destabilization it
might have been i mean abraham lincoln
was a deeply racist individual like re
read the history of abraham lincoln read
about liberia and and like the letters
that abraham lincoln wrote
but it shouldn't be surprising anybody
i'm not trying to impugn the honor of
abraham lincoln i'm just pointing out
back then like literally everybody was
racist and so people people like to look
back and base past history and morality
on modern sensibilities which is just
not correct yeah right abraham lincoln
was and was didn't what did not want to
be the president
during the collapse of the united states
and so it was very political i mean the
dude suspended habeas corpus up through
a corridor from dc through maryland to
pennsylvania where they were just
arresting people without charge and
holding them indefinitely this is not a
guy who believes in freedom and doing
right it's a guy about who who believed
in winning by any means necessary i
think the slavery thing was like a moral
thing for him no he said if i could have
kept the union together without freeing
slaves i would have done it i mean he
was completely dedicated to keeping the
union as a nation i think we're taught
that in school that it is about
slavery and it's about morality because
our sensibilities have changed and i
think if you were president now
in that time you would have behaved
differently but for labraham lincoln it
wasn't about slavery and i think
we're just told to turn a blind eye to
that it was about preserving the union
the economics yeah he wanted the money
from the south
i think it's complicated i mean there's
a really great letter ulysses s grant
wrote where he said that the union
sacrificed blood and treasure to admit
these states into the union
and they swore an oath
by seceding they were in violation of
their oath and effectively stealing that
blood and treasure for you know for
themselves and so he he wrote that um
anyone any man has a right to rebel
against his
against his government or leaders or
authority or whatever just know that if
you lose you will have to live under
their you know
command and penalty you know from that
point forward so it's interesting
actually reading what these guys wrote
about what was going on back then it's
it's truly crazy stuff
let me jump to this next story we'll
keep the conversation going
donald trump warns terrible things are
about to happen to the u.s
this to me actually is more serious than
i think a lot of people probably realize
on the surface
the former president said that the
temperature because the temperature has
to be brought down in this country he's
offering
any assistance to the doj
to try and calm things down
he says if it isn't terrible things are
going to happen
i think donald trump realizes when you
see these the story from axios about a
guy threatening fbi agents about a guy
going to an fbi field office
about uh i mean just the fact they're
going after a president it's not so much
that trump realizes
he's in trouble that they're coming
after him but people are ready to snap
in this country and the left has long
been ready to snap they've been snapping
for a while and now their rights ready
to go out when trump says something like
this
this creates in my mind an image of
trump sitting down at a desk like dead
serious more serious he's ever been
being like
this is bad
this is real bad and i think when trump
notices it it's probably worse than we
even realize
i have to wonder what a secret service
detail is telling him or the things that
he might be seeing
and um i think the left's view of this
probably like ah trump's trying to save
his own skin right
yes he's saying it's look hey there's a
big problem coming for us when what he
means is for me
and then people have a tendency to
externalize their own fears when they're
really in in trouble
i don't i don't think that's what it is
i mean i think he's talking about food
shortages i think he's talking about
inflation that it's all going to get
worse
that things that tensions are high now
but it's going to get much worse you you
and i think that part of it's going to
be
biden's already announced yeah we're
probably looking at some food shortages
he did that months ago i mean it's going
to get bad and then when you start
having bread lines in america you you
see you know i see news reports where
all the food banks are now have you know
40 50 percent increase in how many
people are lining up for food i mean it
if that starts happening then you're
going to see violence do you think that
was the richest country on the earth's
ever seen i feel like you've given up
have you given up do you feel like it's
inevitably going to fall apart and then
just i think that there are forces
within our government that are making it
happen that want it to happen
they are they're trying to force a civil
war what's if you if you accept the
premise like i do that the left is
literally trying to destroy this country
they hate it they hate the constitution
they hate the country is founded they've
been teaching our children for decades
in school that this is a racist evil
country if you think that if you accept
the premise that they want to destroy it
what's the quickest way to do that the
quickest way is the civil war
and not only that the one way to get rid
of a constitution yeah so you can
destroy a civil war by a road i mean you
can destroy a country by eroding it the
problem is when you have a constitution
they struggle you know 100 years on
they've been trying to get rid of the
second amendment and boy it's just not
really working out all that well because
there's new advancements new
technologies they keep kind of passing
they keep keep they keep trying to pass
new bills there's active resistance if
there was no constitution they'd have
banned guns
1850s right 1860 right in the civil war
okay nobody can have guns but us because
we're you know
but they can
there's one way to get rid of it and
that's having a civil war so i have to
wonder
if it's uh china
as many people speculate china is
influence in this one and recently on a
russian state tv
program the they were talking about the
hosts were talking about a civil war is
likely coming to the u.s because the fbi
raided donald trump and one of the hosts
said the only question is which side do
we support with weapons
and i think that exemplifies the world
during the american revolution france
came in with troops and funding because
they knew it was basically help for them
in their fight with britain and they
knew was going to be bad for their
enemies
during the civil war the american civil
war there was funding coming from
external countries to the north and
south because there was a bet on who was
going to win and your investments were
riding on it the cia's funding regime
changes has been doing it for decades
decades i cannot imagine that another
the other countries are not their
versions of cia are not doing that in
the united states they in fact i would
guess that they are
is
essentially attempting to create coups
within the united states probably have
been for decades yuri bezmanov talks
about like this slow sure you know
change of culture is the way to get a
country to change so you don't have to
blow anything up um
uh yeah i don't know if it's a ccp i
can't blame china because they're under
occupation by the ccp right now except
for taiwan
except for the republic the republic
stands in taiwan at the moment it would
be really cool if like you know 50 years
we're looking back and like the republic
of china took back over
ccp collapses that's that's the path
that we're on you think so taiwan is
eventually going to regain control i
think the people of china will revolt
they tried in 91 it but the
the ccp mowed down people in tiananmen
square i'll get a lot of i probably will
get people responding like ian you've
got the history all wrong because i am
looking at it through an american lens
of media but i remember seeing the tank
driving on the street the guy waving his
hands to be like hey
i'm a chinese man i'm sovereign don't
you you don't live here don't you don't
control me and the tanks just like tried
to go around them and then they they ran
them off i thought he was just holding
the bags
i thought he was just holding bags yeah
yeah and then he was like waving
something around like a suitcase or bags
or something like that yep so you said
that you think it's in the government
like like working for the us government
the people have been co-opted by
external governance enemies foreign and
domestic why do you think that
well i think that our government has
been corrupted especially the biden
family i mean you take look at all the
money that's come out of china to the
biden family to come out of ukraine to
the biden family i mean there there's
serious payoffs there and they're not
the only ones i mean
a lot of foreign money has flown
uh has has gone to the clinton family to
even the romney family i mean there's a
lot of corruption here and a lot of
people are protecting their financial
interests and are selling out the united
states and you have that combination
of of as yuri besamo
what's his name basmanov besmanov
besamoff whatever yeah the long march
through the institutions they have
corrupted our our educational system so
that you have generation after
generation increasingly hating this
country increasingly feeling like oh
capitalism is really the problem
and so it's it's a combination of all
those things it's not just a foreign
enemy and it's not just domestic enemies
it's a combination of everything it's
have you seen that movie everything
everywhere all at once yeah i really
really liked it but it kind of feels
like in a sense
the multiverse is collapsing on on us
right now maybe maybe the large hadron
collider needs to stop firing up or
something but you've got 1984 brave new
world fairness 51 you got v for vendetta
you got atlas shrugged just you name it
and they are all getting mashed together
all at once people are commenting right
now like there's not going to be a civil
war it's world war three and i'm like
yeah that too yeah it's just like all
happening i find it hard not to think
about sri lanka right now because they
just had insane inflation and then their
president was like no no i'll step down
after people stormed his home and office
and then he got on a plane and still
hadn't resigned and left the country got
denied entry to singapore and kept going
on you know when you line it up it's
like we also have uh high inflation and
we also have a president that or a
former president that looks like he's
about to be indicted i mean the
instability is so parallel to countries
that i don't think americans are used to
comparing themselves to as as haughty as
that sounds uh and saying sri lanka is
like the dry run yeah i mean i think
it's hard not to be like you i mean they
you were just saying like well trump has
a president has a plane he could leave
on like
it's right there i mean
the sri lankan president because he was
president at the time took a military
plane and because he can't be uh
indicted or anything while he's a
sitting president left with it like it's
it sounds crazy
this is while people were storming his
office his house people were occupying
the prime minister's house like it
sounds crazy but at the same time you
know
that kind of stress and chaos that high
inflation brings we are also feeling it
in america it's just on a micro level in
comparison it doesn't mean that things
can't get out of hand in the same way
and we're just not used to being
compared to countries that we think we
are more stable than
it's that belief that it can't happen
here it can't happen here we think this
all the time
even though it literally is
happening it's it's happening i mean
it's it's fascinating to look at
the circumstances in portland the
various circumstances i mean the
firebombing of the federal building but
worse still is when aaron danielson got
shot twice in the chest by that blm guy
so i mean the feds went after that dude
and claimed he had it went for a gun
they ended up killing him i'm like
that's kind of a crazy story
but you you take all the street level
violence and then you you add in the the
the big the big hits
the former president had his home raided
by the fbi
his former senior advisor i believe uh
bannon was
was what was ben's position
he was the adviser to the president
supervisor
yeah arrested being charged peter
navarro shackled
these things
are you know i mentioned this last week
but uh
i'm curious your thoughts uh nick when
we talk to people or when i read history
about some of these other countries
where civil war happened or revolution
happened
there's like always mass killings and
conflict and
there will they always interview
somebody who left and nazi germany
always being the easiest example for
everybody why did so the jewish family
leaves right before the nazis rise to
power and why
and they say something like we saw them
dehumanizing and demonizing and thought
we better get out of here before it's
too late
then you had uh many even crystal
knocked
they you know the mass destruction of
these jewish businesses people still
stayed
you know despite everything but people
still fled when i see stuff like um the
former president being raided
when i see the fbi saying that symbols
of american history are are extremism
the betsy ross flag the gonzalez flag
the gadsden flag they're telling you
your own history is extremism like these
are all signs that in any other country
at any point other point in history
families were already fleeing seeking
safety in other countries it's happening
now here
i have a friend who told me a story
about talking to his niece about what
she learns in school and he said he said
she'd never heard of the u.s
constitution
she didn't even know what it was he said
don't you say the pledge of allegiance
at school anymore and they she said no
we say a pledge to blm and antifa
we say a pledge to diversity and
tolerance inclusion and they don't say
anything about the actual constitution
of the united states and how this
country was founded is this a private
school in california what is this it's a
it's a school in california is it a
public a public school i'm not sure
about that i got to get this pledge i
want a transcript of this i know i've
heard of this too i want to get it this
is the most wild pledge i've ever heard
of no i've
there's been tons of stories i think
libs of tick tock had the story yeah the
teacher was like we have them all
pledged to the lgbt flag or whatever
wasn't it it was buddha judge's
husband's husband yeah who had a camp
where they did that where they had wow
yeah so you could probably find a video
of it yeah
yeah but the other the other thing i was
going to say is uh
you know the the
the thing about the trump uh
raid at mar-a-lago
it being so galvanizing to me it was
like
i've seen this happening over and over
again to private citizens in the united
states that's what my whole movie is
about and a month ago 6 22 of this year
a woman called me and told me about a
raid that happened at her house this is
like 19 months after january 6th the fbi
storms into her ranch
her and her husband are asleep it's the
middle of the night
they see they have security on their
gate because the
both her and her husband are security
people they they you know trained in
weaponry and stuff they they they
provide security
and
they see people at their gates and she
says this isn't a deer honey there's
people out there and all of a sudden
they just break down the gates they come
barreling down their driveway
swat teams
they're you know throwing flash bangs at
them come out of your house with your
hands up and they're screaming where's
the warrant
what what are you here for
basically they terrorized them they
handcuffed them there's a rental
property on their same ranch they
flashbanged that they said thank god the
the person that rented there wasn't home
but they they they just basically
handcuffed these this couple out on
their lawn
pull the vehicles around their house so
that they couldn't see what they were
doing and went inside for six hours and
ransacked their house
and all the time they're saying what are
you here for
where's the warrant they go we'll show
you when we're good and ready whatever
they said and he finally says what are
you looking for and he says we have a
picture of you says this to the husband
we have a picture of you
attacking a police officer
on january 6 inside the building he said
i never went in the building show me the
picture he says no i will show it to you
later he says
i want to see the picture and he shows
him this blurry picture
he says that's that could be anybody
that's not me i didn't that's not me
and finally after this is all over
they he said where's the warrant one
last time and they said we left it on
the couch and they go in and they look
at the warrants on the couch and it says
they were looking for three items
a trump beanie a trump gator and a puffy
black coat
three articles of clothing
and they terrorize these people in this
way
so why do they do that
what is the point of doing that
it's it it's there's no justice involved
three articles of clothing and fairly
common items yeah i mean any that's
that's like
i was there everybody had a puffy coat
and like a trump hat on him i mean
it's just so generic it could have been
anyone they just specifically wanted to
go but this is a systematic this is not
just happening to trump it's happening
to normal people it's why i'm been
obsessive lately another reason of this
pardon why i think a mass pardon is on
the horizon because it's like this black
blackstone's formula man it's like it's
echo been echoing in my consciousness
it's better that we let a thousand
guilty people go than somebody has to
sit in prison that's innocent
i i i i don't know about the
you know to what extent we could do
pardon because i would not agree with
like
you know hunter biden being part or
anything like that but i will say that i
think we took a wrong turn when this
country decided that we should hand off
our responsibility towards personal
protection to external governmental
agencies so it used to be the
communities were self-policing the local
militia would take care of their local
issues and there was a duly elected
sheriff and maybe a deputy nowadays
cities all have their own departments
where they've monopolies on how to deal
with with these issues and depending on
how big the city is it gets worse and
worse for instance in new york where you
can't have a gun you can't defend
yourself violating the constitution and
your rights i think maybe the issue
should just ultimately go back to you
know what
if uh we you know we need law
enforcement and judicial system for
probably property crimes to deal with
resolving those things but in terms of
you know any other kind of violent crime
or robbery
i think two-way takes care of all that
stuff
polite armed societies applied society
people should have their right to
protect themselves and we should restore
responsibility to the greatest degree we
can to the individuals and so you know
i'm mentioning that in terms of the
pardoning of people perceived as being
violent i'm kind of like yeah you know
what
if someone is convicted duly and it's
proven they've done this beyond a
reasonable doubt by a jury of their
peers by all means
you know they've gone through due
process they can be deprived of their
rights and locked up but for the most
part i'm kind of like
you know we don't need all these cops we
don't need to be dealing with this this
prison system if people are just armed
like second amendment prescribes
yep well you got to protect vigilantism
there you know i don't know it's not
it's not
i understand someone with a gun being
like i thought they were invading my
house i didn't know like that's a big
problem that's why that's that's
property crimes right that's why we do
need some kind of system but i think
dually elected law enforcement i'm
talking about we shouldn't be worried
about walking down the street no we
should have local law enforcement as the
first
the first gate for sure and that should
even protect you from federal law
enforcement that's gone overboard or
state law enforcement's just gone
overboard as your local law enforcement
and if there are none then you have to
take it on your own shoulders that's
what happened to these people that i was
just talking about they reached out to
the sheriff
to say you know
these these people the fbi why were you
allowing them to violate our rights this
way and the sheriff's job should have
been to step in and protect them but he
he wouldn't do anything why
well i don't know i mean i guess he was
afraid i don't know why did he know
about it he knew about it after the fact
you know and they asked him for help and
because what happens to these people
most of the time is that these break-ins
happen and i've talked to a lot of
people that this happened to
the fbi comes and terrorize them then
breaks down their door and does whatever
they do and then they just never hear
from them again
do you think like
they were sitting there waiting for
charges they hire a lawyer charges never
come the lawyer tells them to be quiet
don't say anything because you know we
don't know what the fbi is going to do
so it just kind of puts a hush over
everything and and these people are just
sitting there waiting for the next shoe
to drop the kind of thing where like if
they leave the country just on a
vacation that they could get charged for
as a flight thing right you can't get
charged for leaving that's the thing
about trump's passports too i think it's
a really weird sign
because you're right he wasn't charged
yeah you can leave i mean
they'll say you know don't leave but you
can't tell you what to do you can leave
unless they charge you i think they say
sometimes like when you leave it makes
you look more guilty like they try to
scare you into not going anywhere
because they can't tell you not to go
but they say like well but in court
it'll make like it'll look like you left
the country on this grand conspiracy or
whatever i was going to ask you if you
feel like local law enforcement for the
most part feels like they have to see
jurisdiction to the federal government i
mean from what i know which is very
limited on how law enforcement works
often it becomes once the federal
government has you know whether it be
uh you know the fbi or whatever that
once they get involved with something
they
you know have jurisdiction they are
allowed to take the lead on whatever
case they want often to the detriment
local law enforcement also feels like
that hurts some of the cases they're
working on
well
it varies sheriff the sheriff you know
the sheriff is the local law enforcement
that's elected by those people and you
have strong ones and you have weak ones
do you think if we had more like a
better understanding of federalism and
like the individual governments of state
people would feel like they could hold
their elected sheriffs accountable to
opposing the the fbi yeah and a lot of
the people who run for sheriff run on
that platform
you know we're going to protect your
second amendment rights we're going to
make sure that you know the federal
government can't come in and take your
weapons but then when it happens
they're intimidated and they don't they
don't do anything yeah
do you think in some ways it's because
they
you know i just think about all the um
some of the code regulations and
questions about like if you get uh money
through medicare or medicaid you have to
enforce the things the federal
government has said i wonder if it works
in the same way with law enforcement
they aren't sure what pressure is being
going to be put on them so they just
don't act at all you know yeah i'm sure
it's like that it's like the educational
system too you know there was so much
federal money tied to
mass mandates and to
vaccine mandates that the the school
systems in order to get that federal
money they decided that they have to
comply
i mean this is how we got the drinking
age to where it is right they held the
the highway funding hostage until
everyone would agree to make it 20 21.
yeah thank god they did that you know
after i had already had my fun
where did you grow up
north carolina okay because there were
north carolina was one of the last
holdouts or maybe with south carolina i
can't remember the story completely but
i remember them being like no problem
federalism we love it except
we aren't going to give you any money
for your highways unless you comply i
mean they got really strange they got
shanghaied into doing exactly what
federal government wants which i think
is how for the most part you know so
much of this happens i can only imagine
what it's like to be a part of local law
enforcement that you know worries what
kind of funding they're going to get if
they say no when they already know
you know from my understanding most
local law enforcement is understaffed
anyways yeah
well sheriff villanova in los angeles
county is really one of the better ones
he's he's been doing a really good job
at standing up to some of the mask
nonsense and all the the federal
mandates there
but it it just varies yeah place to
place when you were working on your
movie was like the role of local law
enforcement in the investigation did it
come up a lot in which in your uh movie
on january 6 your documentary
well no because mostly what we wound up
focusing on is the stories of people who
you know were there on january 6 and who
didn't really do anything wrong or
violent and who subsequently got visited
and persecuted and some of whom are put
in jail and none of them said i wish my
local sheriff had stepped in or did they
feel like
their state law enforcement didn't have
anything to do with well it all happened
so suddenly you know it these things
just come and they they come at 5 30 in
the morning six in the morning right
there's no warning
a lot of these people never have been
arrested for anything before in their
lives and in that case you would expect
like a phone call you would expect them
to say we'd like to talk to you there
but instead they just just stand we do
it we do have an update that actually uh
came out just before we started the show
so uh apologies for not seeing this uh
sooner this was posted by kyle cheney of
politico
the trump team is publicizing this email
which shows the doj obtained three
passports two expired not one as trump
said no trump said oh okay trump said
what was expired and alerted trump's
lawyers they were recovered by a filter
team which weeds out privileged info
trump publicized this after dog offered
them doj offered them back oh
interesting so
yes but i don't think that
means anything that last point like
donald trump learned that they took his
passports and then complained they took
my passports right so the email says
evan jim we have learned the filter
agent sees three passports belonging to
president trump to expire one being his
active diplomatic passport we are
returning them and they will be ready
for pickup at wfo at 2pm today i am
traveling but you can coordinate further
with redacted copied above thanks so it
looks like they did take his passports
and it was the the accident narrative i
suppose and trump was correct when he
said they took them
and um
i don't know why it matters that trump
publicized it after after they offered
them back i mean i feel like they're
trying to say like he's so petty they
offered to give him back but it's like
why did they take them in the first
place yeah exactly i don't think that
that's her i mean i think you'll for the
rest of the week we'll see that a lot
well they offer to give it back it's not
that big a deal
but it is it's a huge deal yeah his
active diplomatic passport are you
kidding me they just like stumbled
across it we're like we don't know what
this is so we'll just take it with us
and it's active can he
as a former president can he still use a
diplomatic passport i i guess he can
right
scroll down to the the email again it
says active in there i think no it does
it does but i'm wondering can a former
president use a diplomatic passport yeah
i don't know i mean if it he must be
able to use it otherwise it wouldn't be
active is all i can say to that i i
think that that's right right it must be
privileges for a while i mean i don't
know i'm not as well versed in what what
privileges are extended to the president
like
what is it like if you're in congress
you retain your security passes for life
or something like that is how it works i
don't know but there are extensions like
that and to a certain extent he's still
a
political figure of the united states i
mean he still travels quite a bit and is
a representation of the country
i can only see it there's some
explanation as to why they'd have it
it's such an unprecedented time you know
it's like he's not being treated like
any former president of the united
states he's being treated like a
criminal so
i don't know this is i was just thinking
our legal system the main purpose is to
protect the innocent that is why we
built it that's why we have it in place
it is not to find and destroy guilt or
evil it is to protect innocent people if
someone as a byproduct of the protection
of the innocent is charged
then that's that happens but
it should be that way yes i don't know
if it's always cannot function any other
way otherwise it becomes a
self-persecuting immolation a lot of it
is retribution that's problem that's the
problem that's when societies consume
themselves with restrictions there's 500
people are more in jail in dc right now
most of them have not even been
interested in people because until
they're proven guilty they are innocent
right but their their whole they've been
holding them for over 18 months with no
charges no charges yeah and one of them
there i was told by somebody a friend of
his he's there because he saw something
that happened with roseanne boylan one
of the women who died on january 6th he
saw what happened there and they don't
want him telling what he saw so he can't
write a letter
i don't know i'm just telling you but if
you're just reporting what i was told i
don't know if any of this is if you're
in prison they're controlling yourself
you know it's like you you start kind of
trying to look for any kind of
conspiracy theory any kind of
explanation for why they would hold
somebody without charges for 18 months
it does doesn't make any sense there
must be some reason
well i'm not a fan of that
i should say it's exactly what they say
a lot of law enforcement does to people
of color who are uh held on bad charges
and are not fairly treated it's you know
it always bothers me that there's no
consistency applied if you believe in
criminal justice reform you should
believe in it for everybody but it's
just this is worth overlooking i guess
yeah moral logic isn't the strong point
of the of the left
um that's one of the reasons not a fan
of the death penalty is that often
people say it's just retribution and i'm
like i don't know what is served through
retribution you know i've seen more than
enough movies
comics anime you name it cartoons where
the the protagonist explains revenge
never makes the pain go away it never
solves the problem
i think it was even even batman
explained at one time so i see these
stories and it's just like families you
know i was told by someone
when those families don't get the the
the
you know the justice of watching the
person who you know committed the crime
being put to death or whatever i'm like
i don't know if retribution
is going to solve anything for us or
just an eye for an eye makes the whole
world blind you know
i think it's too much trouble that's why
i'm against the death i'm in favor of
exile i say if you get duly you know
duly convicted you know through due
process or whatever we have a big island
somewhere and we just there you go like
you've been excised like we're not going
to deprive you of your life and liberty
but you've lost all privileges to the
society well that tried that once now
we've got australia yeah
oh no
i think i think doesn't like norway do
that like one of those scandinavian
countries their own island yeah yeah i
think it's sweden that does it they have
like a specific island and prisoners
actually at the end would beg to leave
it because they just
they want to eventually resume the
island yeah they do well of course
they're in jail yeah but it's also like
they're allowed to roam free like it's
not like incarceration in america where
you're like in a cell or anything like
that but it's like tom hanks and
castaway yeah i think that's kind of
what it ends up feeling like i mean in
some ways it doesn't they feel so
disconnected right well but maybe it's
more more like escape from new york
because you're on an island with a bunch
of other people
and the winter comes that must be it's
not a tropical island right there i
don't know but like you're saying they
would rather be in jail in a cell i mean
i think it's that they're so deprived
from society having been a part of it
for so long i haven't read that article
time magazine did an article with this a
long time ago i know we've talked about
it before and i haven't read it in quite
some time so i don't want to misquote it
but i remember there being interviewing
prisoners who were like i wish i could
leave i don't want to be here there are
people in scandinavian countries who
want to go to jail because the jails are
so nice yeah yeah i remember uh talking
with some people i knew because i'd been
over there several times and they were
saying like a lot of a lot of young
people talk about it
just go to jail you know because it's
comfortable they take care of you your
video games play music they'll get your
guitar if you want it man it's like it's
perfect yeah that's that's a really bad
idea
incentivizing crime by rewarding it yeah
i used to know people i grew up in a
rural area but we did have a couple you
know homeless people who would just come
the winter get arrested for some crime
where they'd be incarcerated through the
winter months because really cold rigor
up and then they get released and you
know for the most part they weren't in
they weren't concerned about building a
a record because their lives were sort
of in turmoil anyways but they've got
food shelter you know access to
electricity during uh the most dangerous
time of the year for the homeless which
is the winter there's a that's that
story i can't remember what what said
which jurisdiction wanted to do this but
they wanted to pay criminals i think
california is doing it right now
are they doing it or they tried it or
what they tried it but i think they
ended the program i think it was just
san francisco that tried this yeah it
was like if you don't commit a crime
this month we'll give you 500 bucks or
something like that but if you commit a
crime we'll stop paying you but not
forever like right you could then like
it's like you went into like it's like
if your parents stopped giving you an
allowance for a little while and you're
like okay we'll try it again the problem
with that is then the dude is like i'm
about to steal a thousand dollar car you
know it's a junker but i could flip it
real quick but then i won't get that 500
bucks but i will get a thousand dollar
car opportunity costs i mean exactly
well we just need to give them more
money that's what that's what they do oh
yeah just make them all millionaires
then they'll become corporate criminals
now with a million dollars i'm going to
set up a company that
yeah i think it's like idealistic like
they want to think oh well crime only
stems from poverty and if we can fix
poverty then we can stop crime and for
some people that might be the case you
know they're stealing because they need
to they don't have the resources to get
whatever's going on
but for the most part that's not
actually most motivation for crime and
so we aren't really addressing the
problem we are doing what we want to
believe will solve the problem because
of our morals but we lack the
understanding it really bothers me a lot
of studies of
you know uh
crimes or men and women in general will
exclude men who are in prison and i feel
like if we don't understand the people
who are committing crimes then we can't
really say what will rehabilitate them
we go off of what people who aren't
incarcerated think will fix people i
thought charles manson was a missed
opportunity part of me i really wanted
to interview him before he died because
he never killed anybody he just told
people go f it up and then they went and
they killed and they were like well you
told him you incited it charles and like
he was they were all blasted out on acid
at the time and like
whether or not that's what the story is
that he told them to go eff it up said
the full and then so they went to the
what was it the woman's house and uh
they effed it up all right they killed
like four people or something horrible
but he went to prison for it you see
that quentin i think quentin tarantino
will be yeah yeah i thought that like
brad pitt killed him yeah that's what i
heard yeah you would think that when the
aliens watch the
stories of our people they'll be real
confused
definitely
what's up in hollywood is that what it
was yeah yeah i liked that movie i
thought it was yeah it was good yeah who
was it
was a great character polanski's wife
chanted sharon tate was she wasn't
bianca house i think she was pregnant at
the time she got killed but so so
charles never killed anybody but i think
that that was you could consider that a
violent crime inciting someone to go do
a violent crime
but i need to know that i want to hear
the psychology of it i think that the
world deserves to know and no one in
that group committed prime crimes
because they didn't have enough money
like you couldn't have offered that
group 500 not to commit crimes like that
was their whole thing they were anti the
system and they were anti the government
and they had their own
you know cultish uh world view i mean it
wasn't this ubi that i think it was san
francisco offered that wouldn't have
stopped this in this cadence and that's
why i really think that like we just do
ourselves a disservice by trying to
uh
treat people who are in prison like we
sort of understand them but also
excluding them from a lot of
psychological research because we're
like oh well it's such a strange it's
such a strange environment it's unusual
power dynamics are different there but
you're creating the system and that's
where you're putting people who are
incarcerated who then get released and
it starts over again i just thought
something funny
so like you just said you have to pay
more money right because if he's like
hey i can steal this thousand dollar
laptop i won't get the 500 bucks but i
get the laptop it's worth more right and
then ian mentions an opportunity cost
and then i'm like so they got to pay the
guy more money right so then the city
comes out and says all right fine how
about we give you four thousand dollars
because you're not gonna be able to
steal enough to cover that and the dude
goes wow all right now he's walking
around with you know a thousand bucks a
week some other guy goes he's got a
thousand bucks if i rob him i'll lose my
500. his fractional reserve so he's got
to pay him more money
eventually everybody's just flushed with
cash and the money's worthless yeah and
then they start stealing food yeah
stupid i mean you've seen those
interviews
with guy drug addicts who've moved to
san francisco because they get a stipend
right they get done wow yeah that's what
they have interviews with them where he
goes you know that's why i came here
moved there from alabama well you know
that does though
when they do the census they get more
residents more more seats
more constituents and then what they
were doing in northern california was
they were
interning the homeless i think it was
they were uh putting them in camps they
couldn't leave and then seizing their
assets
yep nice they were like you cannot
support yourself so now we're taking you
and any money you'd receive is we're in
control of which is insane i used to be
like overwhelmed with compassion that i
want to help everybody that would be
i'll help them all all of them and then
i'm like as i'm growing and watching the
universe like some people are i mean
we're animals
yeah they're more animal than human you
could say i mean humans are animals but
they're more animal than consciousness
or something i mean we're all
consciousness animals you know but some
of these people are just like so this in
the in the carnal
you know base reality that it's impos
not impossible but
challenging to get through to them and
then i'm just watching it from afar and
i'm like how do you how do you deal with
that we're gonna go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and share the show with your
friends head over to timcast.com we're
gonna have that members only segment
coming up uncensored at about uh 11 p.m
and it's funny whenever people like
mention periodically we have
particularly uncensored episodes and
sometimes it means like politically
incorrect sometimes it means crazy
subject matter or we just swear a lot
but that's the after-hours show at
timcast.com and again smash that like
button let's read some super chats all
right
j-a-e-u-f-m says maybe trump should go
to texas and seek asylum from the
governor
i don't think that works that way
because it's federal issues although
maybe new york or whatever
raymond stanley jr says what's this tim
cast records i've been hearing about we
are launching music we have a song
coming out in about a week and a half
week and a half are you going to sing a
sample right now i am not no
i used to sing on friday nights on tim
cast ireland we're planning on bringing
that back actually but uh we'll see
we've been talking about for a while
that's why we have this other extra area
set up we you never see in the back of
the room the room's pretty big but um
with the new place that we're building
the steel frames have gone up but
fridama stand 40 feet in the center it's
crazy we're to have a stage and be able
to do live shows so we'll actually be
able to have like musical guests on like
friday nights or something it's going to
be so it's going to be really amazing
we'll do a commercial and we'll be like
ladies and gentlemen here's a band and
then everyone claps and then the camera
pans over no i'm just kidding i hope you
keep that the end here's a band here's
another thing it would be like stephen
colbert then yeah yeah yeah like a
nightly show now we wouldn't do it like
that we would do like friday you know we
used to do at the end of friday night we
would play some songs
and uh we're planning on bringing that
back and we're also looking at getting a
venue in the west virginia area so that
we can actually do friday night live the
whole event live ticket sales extended
this really cool stuff
cool all right no legs no problem tv
says nostalgia watching days of thunder
saw trooper nick cersei delivering
strippers to tom cruise this isn't
transporting this is consumption
that was my first movie oh wow how long
ago was it
1991.
wow 90 maybe 90 maybe 19 how did it
change your world to get that role
you know i just moved down there from
new york i'd been in new york for seven
years doing theater and my wife had
gotten pregnant and we moved back to
north carolina because we didn't want to
have the baby in our fourth floor walk
up and uh started auditioning for little
parts there in north carolina
and uh
went in an audition for tony scott i
remember my knees were shaking when i
auditioned and i just thought well i
screwed that up
and then like a month later they called
me and they said yeah you got that part
one you just auditioned once no
callbacks no combat and so when i went
in like the first scene i ever did was
with tom cruise and robert duvall
wow so cool amazing wow and it was kind
of you know it's a nice scene it's like
i i kind of pulled them over and set
them up for this joke and it's like i
had all the lines
crazy it was like my little my little
movie where tom tom and robert were
extras all right
slappy mccracken says don't forget today
is afghanistan independence day thank
you joe biden
oh yeah i think there's a republican
inquiry isn't there they're pushing some
they're gonna release their report
they wanna know they keep calling it a
withdrawal i start calling it a
surrender you guys but you're on the
right track i think you know i agree
with you on that but i kind of feel like
is there a word we can use that's worse
than surrender yeah capitulation yeah
route but you can have a surrender and a
route
i mean
surrender makes sense but it kind of
feels like he intentionally helped the
extremists with the abandoning of bagram
air force
uh sedition when you help the enemy
no that's treason oh treason that's what
they call that
potentially
[Laughter]
all right let's see
aaron cowell says nick loved your role
in from the earth to the moon question
how was it playing deke and being such
an uh and being such an interesting
story
that was terrific i got to talk to bobby
slayton deke's widow
deke was he was not alive at the time we
shot that but a lot of the astronauts
came down we met
like tim scott and some i mean dave
scott and some of the other astronauts
but that was a that was a great time we
shot in orlando got the shootout on
cape canaveral and uh
got to work with i think i met every
middle-aged white actor in hollywood at
that time we were all playing astronauts
i just i just remembered something
because of that too um i have just
secured
340 life magazines going back from to
the 50s to the 70s and i went to an
antique antique shop out in west
virginia and they had a few one of them
was the astronauts from the moon landing
and it was life magazine with like this
low res photo printed on you know paper
magazine
and then i was like i definitely want to
buy that there were some newspapers
there we got i got one newspaper washed
in times florida calls it for bush
really excited about that one and then
the woman there told me that she had a
whole bunch of the life magazines went
back 340. it's remarkable reading 1962
like what they were talking about when
the draft started for vietnam i got the
life magazine from that wow super cool
stuff so we've got all of these boxes
like seven or eight boxes of all these
magazines we're gonna sort them out by
date
i just think it's fascinating um
and important and i think we i actually
want to put together maybe like put
my my thought process on it was put
together a report to look at major
historical moments from the lens of the
mod of their current time based on what
we've learned so you know when you go
back and start reading about vietnam in
these magazines they're going to talk
about how we were attacked in the gulf
of tonkin now you look at the modern
reporting on it's like nope it's going
to be really fascinating to see this the
differences in disparities between what
they were claiming and what ended up
being you know true or at least accepted
as true yeah so that's cool stuff i'm
excited for that quick sidebar about
from the earth of the moon the coolest
thing that happened was that we got
invited to show one episode of the show
at the white house
so they flew about six of us in and we
uh had a screening there with bill
clinton and hillary and i got to
i got to shake hands with bill clinton
which is a very interesting story but
it's long
run
bad b says tim and crew got my mom to
listen in lol to friday's show
told her she should tell my sister who
listens to you as well right on i
appreciate it man thank you very much
bad b says falcon laser book called troy
rising should be made into that movie
you want done
what movie
i don't know was that me what movie that
are you movie was then laser book i
don't know
troy rising
all right let's grab a super chat scott
turcotte says they live starring ian
directed by tim poole and co oh they
live too oh they're still alive they're
still here yeah they live it's awesome
right roddy piper
never seen it you know what it is though
right no so it's like he finds
sunglasses when he puts them on he can
see reality oh that's what these could
be we'll find the sunglasses that rowdy
used in the movie i'll find them and
i'll be like
yeah yeah but so like the sequels of
that that picture we have on the wall of
nancy pelosi pulling her face off
the the last panels what the aliens
looked like
so that's the joke uh these youngsters
do you know anything about they live are
you no so he finds better stuff this is
such a fun thing to learn about the guy
that rowdy writing piper the xwf
wrestler finds these glasses and when he
puts them on he sees like billboards
that are normally just billboards they
say things like obey or submit you may
see memes from the money i i do know
this reference
the money says this is your god on it
and then like he looks and he and he
looks at like one of the aliens and they
look back and they're like i think he
can see us yeah like some of the people
turn out to be like the npcs turn out to
be aliens or something like why did this
movie come out it sounds like a good
time
yeah rowdy roddy piper it's like a
10-minute fight scene where they just
have punchy daft movie nights
yeah yeah before after you're called
after they live you have to see hell
comes to frog town that's another great
roddy party
roddy piper is the last fertile man on
the face of the earth and the the earth
has been inhabited by frog people so
he's kidnapped by sandal bergman and a
group of amazonian
women who are trying to preserve him
because his sperm can produce actual
human beings instead of frog people
and so the frog people are trying to
kidnap rodney roddy and kill him
what is this called this also hell comes
to frog town
it's the best
1988
cast movie night double feature
roddy piper plays sam hell that's his
name maybe we can do like uh this is one
of the reasons i want to do a venue
because we could do special events where
we'd like play a movie and then comment
yeah hang out that'd be super fun
science theater baby yeah exactly
i think they made a sequel
did they really i think so i have like a
strong no sequels policy but that one
sounds like it might be worth it i'm
telling you alien 2 is good jake reilly
says wrong trump has said uh has said
something terrible is going to happen to
this country don't sensationalize you
reported earlier trump said terrible
things are going to happen if this
country's temperature isn't brought down
fair point i do think it's comparable uh
like i think it's a similar statement
but i do respect the precision and
making sure you you you get it correct
so i will accept that
all right you were right nick return to
frogtown is the sequel of how come
somebody is robbie thank you i don't
think pipe oh yeah no no i don't think
rowdy's in there not piper
if he's not in it then he can't be in
our uh
movie night my wife dances in california
with sandal bergman who's the star of
conan the barbarian and also hell comes
to frogtown and all that jazz she was
the lead dancer and all that jack oh
cool oh this is going eli m says tim
with crowder coming to charleston west
virginia can we expect him to make an
appearance instead of a civil war could
destabilize destabilization be prepping
us for a switch to fusion oil no longer
matters and neither does the dollar
that's big news charleston is very far
away was it four or five hours four
hours away i thought four but hannah
claire knows better i think it's well
it's probably five from where we are
yeah uh so that's not nothing like we'll
first crowder's
so crowder's actually coming to
baltimore which is closer yeah which one
oh yeah he's coming through our range
that's right he'll be around uh crowder
we gotta have crowd around no one should
be able to come to west virginia without
coming exactly at the very least we
gotta keep her gotta show crowder the
studio and invite them to come down and
we got these great little cookies that
say step on snack and find out that i
ordered they're really fantastic
they're 130 calories each so they're
nightmarishly good for you super
different but the other thing too is
we're we're reaching out we reached out
to jimmy dore i'm really excited for
jimmy he'll also be in the area so maybe
we'll be able to coordinate with uh with
him as well beautiful jimmy's great yeah
one of the best hey yeah and shout out
to the guy i mentioned fusion uh they
just
released an article um exclaiming that
they have tested and confirmed ignition
which is the first time the system's
putting out more energy than is going
into it uh although i don't think they
were able to keep it on it's it's
capturing the energy is is the challenge
right it's giving off so much heat now
they got to figure out a way to restore
to get the heat to turn it back into
electricity to keep the current going
but this is gonna
is gonna be big
if if they can uh if they can stabilize
normalize and you know get fusion out
there
there's gonna be nuts
it's gonna be crazy bonkers free energy
basically like not free but like the
energy costs will become so insanely
cheap that you're not even going to
notice
and uh the climate change people
probably should freak out because what
will happen is there's not going to be
carbon carbon emissions from it but it's
that this energy will ramp up production
to such an insane degree like
fusion's legit man this is going to be
crazy
the bahamian rain man says given her
status as a moderate democrat would it
be completely insane for either senator
trump to pick tulsi gabbard as their
running mate or how even bernie sanders
it'd be such a reach across the aisle
with an olive branch in hand i mean
tulsi just didn't she just host for
tucker carlson yes yeah last week so
anything could happen we can call her a
moderate democrat but like you know
tulsa's in the same camp we are here as
far as the left is concerned she's far
right you know what i mean as for bernie
the world socialist website called
bernie sanders a nationalist capitalist
so you know there's that
bernie is old though i just want to put
that one on the table he'll be like 83
at the next inauguration like
maybe he doesn't maybe he'll just be an
advisor yeah he missed his opportunity
to go independent 2016 after the dnc
screwed him over he should have went
independent that was his chance i don't
think he's going oh there's too much
money in it for him to stay put
all right track a taxi says from a john
from john tester
dmt intern ours losing both georgia
seats in 2020 was worst case scenario
dem strategists didn't believe reps
would f up that badly
i mean yeah i didn't think so either and
then this gave the 50 50 to the
democrats with the tie-breaker to kamala
and now they got the the inflation
reduction act the deflation act can we
please yes did you see what uh
what was it abc said to john pierre
whatever that it was like orwellian what
is it he's like how can you call it the
inflation reduction act when they're
going to be spending all this money it's
it's orwellian he said something like
that i don't got to look up excited i
didn't i was reading about it what was
her response
oh probably huh
yeah what's orwellian how could you say
that to me i don't know what that means
or well he is not orwellian because
george orwell didn't write it yeah there
you go yeah
all right let's see let's grab some
super chats she's such a wild press
secretary
i don't know what to make of her i was
doing a kamala harris voice i'm really
excited
i'm really excited for this prior divine
says thank you for having the ceo of
public square on last week it helped me
feel less alone at the edge of the mind
available on amazon now
i heard that you were a culture building
i want to join um no we did a segment on
publix have you heard of public square
nick yeah
lydia was telling me about it yeah this
very topic
what is this strange squeaking
hear that
would be invaded by aliens probably
what is it did you do this did you bring
the aliens here we're going to contact
you first
we sent him a postcard you're just like
well on that eight if you got it
yeah no that was like a weird metallic
thing i don't know what that was
anyway
public square we did a segment about it
the segment's got 206 559 views i told
michael so this is fantastic yeah um
public square is an app where it shows
you businesses that believe in american
values
so if you're a business you can sign up
and say i agree with these stated values
of the platform and then it's stuff like
the constitution is good it should be
protected things that we we agree with
and then you can go and give your money
to people who don't hate you
absolutely incredible so when i saw the
segment about it was doing really really
well that just makes me feel really
great because it means more people are
going to learn about it
and uh we've got a bunch of restaurants
and businesses around us that are on the
app so like that's where i'm going from
now on yeah uh nfp and and if there's
somewhere i have to go like a hardware
store or something i'll ask them
we got a barbecue joint that they're on
the app super exciting it's west
virginia though so this whole area is
moga county when you're traveling that
it becomes important i guess hollywood
needs that app but there'd only be like
two or three things on it no it's huge
yeah yeah yeah so uh are you are you
living in hollywood sometimes sometimes
check out the app because we started we
pulled it up there's actually a ton of
businesses oh cool now obviously out of
the you know 50 000 or so businesses
that might be there you might find a you
know 500 hey but you'll get what you
need and you'll get it from good people
also did you need 50 000 choices anyways
it's better to narrow down the pool
that's fair choice fair point
oh if you guys want to watch that full
episode michael seifert it was the guest
he's the ceo of public square good
episode too yeah really fun yeah
all right
let's grab some super chits
let's grab some sweets angel torres says
please get jimmy dore on the show then
we can have timmy jimmy power hour from
nickelodeon shout out to graham
uh yeah we've reached out to jimmy
before i've been on his show before
it's really hard to get people on your
show when they do their own show you
know because he does his own show but
he's doing a comedy tour he'll be on the
east coast so i reached out to him and
and it's possible um i would be that
would be it would be so amazing to have
jimmy on it would be a really great show
you know what
when is crowder going to baltimore i
think in december how am i oh okay so
not the same time yeah it would be
absolutely hilarious if we had jimmy and
crowder at the same time yeah that'd be
great
i'd be like let's talk about what we
agree on guys calm down we agree we're
agreeing on this part it would be very
loud i feel like yeah jack's bff says
tim i dare you to put on twitter that
biden should pardon the january 6
americans incarcerated i dare you
okay
he dared you he dared you you're gonna
have to do it now why wouldn't i do it
because well i guess you'll see what
will happen
he dared
i'm phrasing it as a mass pardon of
all over the place i don't want it to
seem like a political move it's just got
to be an american move
you guys are watching
but then he would have to admit that
they're americans in all january yes and
that crimes have been committed in order
to pardon hunter biden for instance you
got to at least admit that there was a
well actually could you pardon someone
that hasn't committed any crimes could i
just say hannah clara you're pardoned
you can't especially if they're in jail
yeah you can pardon them
okay so i could pardon what it feels
like i pardoned everyone that would just
be like
maybe like this guy's gone and
completely insane
maybe
all right so here's what i'm writing
he's doing you can't dare tim and not
take it seriously
he's tweeting it right now
why would i not take this well biden
should pardon all january 6th defendants
as an olive branch to help lower the
political conflict and escalation that's
a good idea
i like that underneath right i was there
to do this no i mean i'm just kidding i
don't know like if i literally say it on
this show why wouldn't i tweet it as
well i will say the funny thing is there
are people who only know me from twitter
and their view of me is hilarious
twitter profile basically yeah because i
tweet nonsense half the time like i
usually tweet the opposite of what i'm
trying to say because it flies in the
face of the sensors
or like
okay you know what i can't mention the
thing i was gonna mention because
we'll have to mention it on the after
show it has to do with the greyhound in
france and so if you're familiar with
what that story oh yeah and why i'm not
but
[Laughter]
but uh this after show is gonna get
really bad and it's gonna include art
from george alex opolis of course it
will
of course do you know do you know what
story this is no okay well i can't
don't want to spoil it i can't wait can
i allude to it no no just just i just
want to give the tip of the iceberg
okay
yes it's about a dog okay
you're going to lose you know i'm just
going to i'm going to say this
professionally as possible
oh
all right i know what this is in an
article published by the lancet we've
encountered the first human-to-dog
transmission of monkey pox i will leave
it there okay leave it there and
elaborate i remember this yes yeah oh my
gosh
oh man
look i don't it's not an issue for
youtube it's an issue for family
friendly people might have kids watching
to the members only and then talk about
this because uh because you don't have
any kids that are members only well well
it's just we
we segment it and such that like people
know if they turn this show on we try to
avoid yes you know we try to keep it
like you know like if it was any other
late night show right but the after
hours one it's like you know what you're
getting into yeah put your kids to bed
we're gonna go to town now
[Laughter]
all right all right all right
cam girl asuna says tim talks about
fleeing and being non-violent but what
is the viable alternative if this the
last best hope of freedom on earth falls
we have nowhere to flee to and no one to
defend us i will have liberty at any
cost
i'm not i'm not advocating for fleeing
the country i'm pointing out that there
have been points in history where people
fled the country there have been points
in history where people stayed and
defended their country and won i'm just
saying
we're at that point like obviously i'm
not leaving you know but when you start
seeing the previous administration be
arrested investigated all that crazy
stuff
that is like
the
that
that happening is
not a red flat well it is a red flag
it's a very large 40 foot tall red flag
with a sickle and a hammer on it but it
is like
we're well past the point where you
should be looking for red flags they
have
raised the flag up very high for
everyone to clearly see at this point
no it's not warning signs anymore
yeah no now at this point it's like we
are watching them put the flag up
all right
jesse barris is according to robert
barnes trump had a blanket declassified
order in place during his presidency any
documents trump trump took out of the
white house was automatically
declassified and i'm pretty sure that's
the case regardless of if even says it
he's allowed to just
take stuff and be like it's not
classified i'm taking it can he say like
here this isn't this is declassified for
you but anyone else that finds that it's
classified i don't believe so no i feel
like that's more like granting someone
temporary security clearance which would
probably be much harder to keep track of
right
um from what i know about security
clearances which is minimal but
uh you know you would be like oh it's
it's okay for you to see it right now
like it's either it's classified or it's
not got it eric boyd says nick do you
watch the orville i think you said no
you didn't see it i saw the
de-transitioning episode tim talked
about it was about de-transitioning for
sure but they thought they told a
transitioning story fan since seven days
um
eric i disagree
so
i think it's a it's a bit of a cynical
view
uh the orville for those that are aren't
uh familiar it's seth macfarlane's space
uh show kind of like star trek they did
an episode early on in 2017 in the
second season where one of the one of
the alien uh you know members of his
crew
alien officers
wants the doctor to perform a sex change
operation on his baby because his baby
was born female but their planet doesn't
like females it's like a 99.999 male of
society so any any child born female he
describes it as if a human was born with
a cleft lip you would repair it would
you not this is the same thing we see
and seth macfarlane literally says you
want to perform a sex change operation
on a baby that is unethical immoral you
can't do that
and so what ends up happening is the
child grows up and in the later season
this this new season which is the jokes
are all gone it's very serious the child
says i'm not supposed to be this way i
want to go back to the way i was and
there's a conflict over and then
ultimately they
detransition the kid back to female
but here's the reason why i don't agree
with they thought they were telling a
transitioning story the argument there
is seth macfarlane was trying to be
pro-sex change for children
i don't think so because
the the later story is that
females from the planet of age
are smuggling females off the planet to
prevent sex changes of minors
like they're quite literally saying 17
18 20 year old whatever adult females
are being smuggled off the planet so
they don't have to undergo sex changes
like they were outright saying like
you could argue that they were saying it
was wrong to force a sex change on a
minor or whatever but the story was not
that they were telling people to
transition i think it was really really
good i think um
the show episode domino
is like the the ninth episode was it's
an hour and 20 minutes long it's a movie
basically it's like a star wars star
trek kind of movie and uh it was really
really well well made
now i have some critiques seth about
what i think you should have done with
this story no i was really really good
i'm i'm really impressed i think orville
is a fantastic show they uh it it's a
bit wokey in some some aspects but i'm
fine with that as long as it's like
actually trying to address certain
issues and explore them so
i'm a fan i think it's great i think
seth mcfarlane's got really awful
political views but you know
you know he did a good job on this one
scott grimes is a fantastic actor yeah
he's um
uh uh what's his i forgot i forgot the
character's name obviously says
lieutenant gordon malloy malloy
i just got to say though i don't like
that they have him sing and play guitar
all the time because it's really out of
place and takes up too much time
but like
yeah seth like yes that's good you know
he's a great singer um i'm pretty sure
he does uh um
the son on american dad yeah steve
steve oh yeah steve yeah his name yeah
yeah
yeah it is yeah he was in band of
brothers and i thought he was one of the
best parts of that of that movie huh
highly recommend it eddie says just went
solar last week so of course fusion will
get cracked now yeah
solar's still good though to keep you
off the grid you know what i mean so you
don't have to worry about it but uh man
i'm super excited for fusion
now it would be really great when they
get miniaturized fusion and we run our
cars off of it and then you your car
runs forever basically pour a little
head pour a little water in
pour a little water pour a little water
in your tank and then get a little
fusion i identify with that guy's fuel
then they'll find a way to sell the
water
yeah uncontrollable power supply is an
interesting
problem i'm sure they've been
considering for decades
all right terence grime says north
carolina here in the beginning i hated
hearing ian he's grew on me so much the
show isn't complete without him rock on
brother oh yeah um michael malus told me
he said at first i didn't understand why
you had ian on the show but now i really
get it and i was like i don't i don't
know what he thinks that means i don't
know i was like i just i just think that
the simple thing is
while there's obviously like
people are on the fence about ian some
people are often saying you know they
don't like what he's saying people say
they love what he's saying
i think one of the problems a lot of
shows face is like i don't i don't want
to make a homogenous show you know like
we need we need somebody who uh is is
looking at things very very differently
someone actually had a really great
super chat last week where they said ian
often reflects the public very well
in how he sees things and and and thinks
about him
i think that's right you're the man of
the people that's it bring me to the top
but they were just basically saying he's
got like a normie perspective on
politics compared to you for sure i
don't study this stuff before i come in
kind of on purpose it is nice to know
what we're talking about before we get
into it but i like learning about it in
real time i think that we talk about
such like hot topics and hard like you
look around the world's like a powder
cake in a lot of ways that i want to at
least make people laugh or bring joy in
some way while we're talking about this
because this stuff needs to be talked
about you haven't made me laugh once
well you're impossible
you're an impossible target nick i know
it's true got you
derek d says your local sheriff and
police get huge amounts of money and
equipment from the feds the last thing
they're going to do is go against the
federal government
yup
that is true and correct
when people talk about the
militarization of police they're often
referring to heavy federal funding
subsidizing which puts them basically in
a de facto chain of command
but they're also talking about like m
raps and you know
heavy armor and weapons i don't think
the issue is militarization
i don't care if a cop has armor and a
rifle i care that he's not suppressing
my rights by all means you got armor and
a rifle the people got armor and rifles
good somebody shows up and wants to
commit a crime i hope you can stop them
if you see a regular person you know
driving their car and then you illegally
search their car now you got a problem
all right let's see
let's uh we'll try and grab uh one more
here mf says hey tim you always talk
about how it's so important that we make
art and culture well hopefully i've done
just that and need your help getting the
word out it's called overdrive michael
fine t-y
what is that is that your things that
we're working on okay well there you go
overdraft um i think cass castle is
finally coming out tomorrow
pilot episode um it is it is basically
behind the scenes with with jokes the
for for people who are big fans of it
i'll just you know reiterate the last
video we did it's just not sustainable
to to have the degree of editing filming
and everything want to do the show was
making like a thousand bucks a month but
it was costing substantially more than
that and there were people saying things
like you were making money off it you
know and i'm like no but i don't like
the idea of having 125 000 subscribers
and then just being like meh didn't make
enough so all of you fans you get
nothing i was like okay maybe if we can
convince 500 to 1000 of those
subscribers to just pay 10 bucks a month
as members to watch that and all our
other content we can keep the show going
and i think that's a better route to go
considering we do want to do a vlog we
do want to film fun stuff and funny
stuff here we got to find a way to make
it work and it was just getting too
expensive and we're subsidizing it so
maybe this will work now
and create a new reason for people to
become members at timcast.com check out
the after hours show that's coming up
and it's going to be really really
unfamily friendly so you're being warned
it's about a dog
yeah
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel and uh share the show with your
friends again timcast.com for the
members only show nick you want to shout
anything out
yep tara on the prairie
go see it at dailywire.com it's a
terrific movie western and i'm the title
role i'm the terror yeah oh that's you
the terror horrifying uh i'm hannah
claire brimlow i'm a writer for
timcast.com i encourage you guys check
it out for your news every day click on
the read tab you can see stuff from me
and a bunch of other people and this
week i am co-hosting pop culture crisis
with brett
so watch me hostilely take over
hostilely take over his show uh several
times a week at three o'clock it's live
every day and you can check me out on
instagram i'm hannah claire.b yeah if
you go to timcast.com at 3 p.m you will
see the live player right there up top
and then of course when tim castro iral
goes live boom right there on the front
page of timcast.com we are exploring um
trying to get the apps going again so
stay tuned for all that all right uh you
guys follow me ian crossland.net if you
want to get through to me on social
media that's the portal and i'll i'll
see you there nick fantastic to see you
again you look so happy by the way i
didn't stare and i know you look like
you wanted to choke my neck or something
no no you didn't make it laughs i just
like you very much you're just not very
funny
thank you for being honest it's always
great to see you thanks again for doing
capital punishment um
yes and for pioneering this
capitalpunishment.locals.com that's
where you can see it cool dude yeah see
you later thank you guys please don't
make me go through this episode after
the show tonight alone come join us at
timcast.com i'm scared i'm not gonna
make it you guys can follow me on
twitter and minds.com at sour patch list
as well as sour patch let's stop me
i'm just warning all of you we are not
going to mince words starting off this
members only show we're going right for
it so thanks for hanging out and we'll
see you all over at timcast.com bye guys
you